Jeder Bürger muss die zentralen Schritte der Wahl ohne besondere technische Vorkenntnisse zuverlässig nachvollziehen und verstehen können.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 118. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich freue mich, dass ihr wieder dabei seid bei einer weiteren Ausgabe hier im Programm, das in letzter Zeit so häufig erscheint. Und der Grund dafür ist vielschichtig, vor allem passiert immer so viel, weil das man unbedingt berichten muss und abgesehen von den ganzen Grundlagenthemen, die hier eigentlich immer mal wieder zur Sprache kommen, den interessanten Projekten, die unbedingt mal vorgestellt werden müssen, gibt es dann auch immer wieder mal aktuelle gesellschaftliche Ereignisse, die hier auch eingefangen werden sollen. Und ja, so ist es auch heute. Heute möchte ich hier auf ein Thema zu sprechen kommen, was auch im Prinzip schon zweimal zu Gast war bei Chaosradio Express, nämlich das Thema der Wahlcomputer, zweimal das Thema war es bereits in der Ausgabe 39, wo es um den NEDAP-Hack ging, wo es einfach mal ganz konkret um die Innereien des in Deutschland und in Holland eingesetzten Wahlcomputermodells der Firma NEDAP ging. Das war mir die technische Analyse ähnlich gelagert, weil die Sendung Ausgabe Nummer 50 zum Wahlstift, einem ähnlich gelagerten System, was seinerzeit in Hamburg eingesetzt werden sollte. NEDAP ist mittlerweile nicht mehr in Holland vertreten mit ihren Wahlcomputern, weil sich die Holländer dagegen ausgesprochen haben. Auch das Hamburger Modell wurde dann gekippt und nun ist es offensichtlich auch in Deutschland soweit, denn am 3. März hat das Verfassungsgericht in Deutschland sich geäußert zu dem Thema Wahlcomputer, weil eine Klage anhängig war. Und diese Klage wurde angeführt unter anderem von Ulrich Wiesner, den ich jetzt bei Chaosradio Express begrüße. Hallo Ulrich. Hallo Tim. Ja, du bist es gewesen. Du hast da gesessen und hast Klage geführt, gemeinsam mit deinem Vater, muss man dazu sagen. Und hast dich ja auch schon vorher lange, lange Zeit mit diesem Thema beschäftigt, warst auch ein-, zweimal auf dem Kongress, glaube ich, schon mit einem Vortrag vertreten. Ist richtig, ne? Zwei Mal?
Dreimal.
Dreimal schon. Ja, und ich wollte jetzt anlässlich dieses Urteils einerseits über das Urteil selber, aber eben auch noch mal generell über die Frage Wahlcomputer reden. Deswegen bin ich jetzt hier in Kronberg im Taunus, im schönen Frühling muss man sagen. Der Winter ist schon vorbei, zumindest hier.
Zumindest diese Woche.
Zumindest diese Woche. Ja, aber vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen zu dir. Vielleicht kannst du ja noch mal kurz ausführen, was dich eigentlich auf dieses Thema gebracht hat und was sozusagen der Grund war, dass du dich da auf diese lange Reise begeben hast, die jetzt bis zum Verfassungsgericht ging.
Ja, eines schönen Samstags im Sommer 2005 habe ich im Hof gesessen und gefrühstückt. Und es war einer der Samstage, wo morgens die CT im Briefkasten ist. Und da war ein Artikel drin von Herrn Siedmann, der hieß dreimal drücken fertig. Und da wurde vorgestellt, genau diese NEDAP-Geräte und das davon bei der Bundestagswahl 2005, ungefähr 2.000 Geräte zum Einsatz kommen sollten. Da bin ich eigentlich aus allen Wolken gefallen, weil ich eigentlich bei dieser ganzen USA-Diskussion über Wahlmaschinen und Wahlcomputer immer den Eindruck gehabt habe, oder die Meinung gehabt hatte, wie schön das so etwas bei uns nicht gibt und dass wir davor sicher sind, weil bei uns sind Wahlen ja öffentlich und dann kann man sowas ja nicht einsetzen. Da hatte ich mich aber doch irgendwie ganz schön vertan.
Du bist sozusagen in die Realität aufgewacht, dass diese Geräte nicht nur vor der Tür stehen, sondern tatsächlich auch schon längst zum Einsatz kommen.
Genau, und es stellte sich sogar heraus, dass sogar mein Wahlkreis betroffen war. Das war damals der Wahlkreis Offenbach. Und da gibt es zwei Gemeinden, nämlich Obertausen und Langen, die diese Geräte schon mehrfach eingesetzt hatten und auch bei der Bundestagswahl einsetzen wollten. Ja, und war ich also plötzlich auch mit betroffen.
Was ist da so dein eigener technischer Hintergrund, dass du da so besorgt drüber nachgedacht hast?
Ich arbeite für ein amerikanisches Software-Unternehmen, angefangen als Programmierer und habe dann so Implementierungsteams geleitet. Das heißt, ich bin jetzt kein Wahlrechtsspezialist und auch kein Sicherheitsspezialist, aber ich habe beruflich genügend mit Computern und Programmen zu tun, um die Problematik ganz ordentlich einschätzen zu können.
Die Problematik, dass die Geräte eigentlich nicht unbedingt immer das tun, was man glaubt, was sie tun?
Ja, dass sie eben das tun, was der Algorithmus vorschreibt und nicht notwendigerweise das, was der Benutzer glaubt, das getan werden soll.
Wie bist du denn da rangegangen? Also was?
Meine erste spontane Reaktion auf diesen Artikel, in dem unter anderem auch beschrieben wurde, wie die Geräte zugelassen werden, nämlich nach einer Untersuchung eines Baumusters durch die Physikalische Technische Bundesanstalt, erfolgt dann eine Zulassung durch das Ministerium des Innern. Und ja, das hat mich dann interessiert und dann habe ich eine E-Mail geschickt, irgendwie noch am gleichen Tage an das BMI und gesagt, kann ich bitte mal so einen Prüfbericht haben. Und da kam dann relativ schnell, also nach wenigen Tagen, eine E-Mail zurück mit der Antwort, ja, vielen Dank für Ihre E-Mail, aber den Prüfbericht können wir Ihnen leider nicht schicken, weil da gibt es ja die Firmengeheimnisse des Herstellers und deswegen können Sie so einen Bericht nicht haben. Und das hat mich dann doch schon ziemlich überrascht, muss ich sagen. Und das hat mich dann auch angestachelt, da nachzufassen. So, und jetzt kam dazu oder kommt dazu, dass mein Vater ein Politikwissenschaftler ist, der sich schon seit, ja im Prinzip seiner ganzen akademischen Karriere, immer wieder mit Wahlen und Wahlsystemen auseinandergesetzt hat. Also er ist kein Jurist oder Wahlrechtler oder sowas, aber er hat sich auseinandergesetzt, wie sich zum Beispiel unterschiedliche Wahlsysteme, also zum Beispiel Mehrheitswahlrecht oder Verhältniswahlrecht auf politische Stabilität auswirken und solche Geschichten. Und deswegen waren bei uns Wahlen immer ein Thema und er hat sich auch immer wieder im Ausland Wahlen angeguckt und Wahlen beobachtet. Und als ich noch ganz klein war, also ein Grundschüler, hat er mich auch mitgenommen in Wahllokale nach der Wahl zur Auszählung. Und deswegen war das für mich einfach immer selbstverständlich, dass so eine Wahl öffentlich ist und transparent, dass man da zugucken kann und dass man sieht, was da passiert. Und das war auch ungeblieben klar, dass das bei solchen Wahlcomputern halt nicht geht. Und da kann man dann, wenn man da zusehen will, zwar immer noch den Wahlcomputer sehen, aber ja nicht, was drin passiert. Das heißt, was man da sieht, ist, dass man nichts sieht. Und da wird dann das Öffentlichkeitsprinzip der Wahl zu so einer Art Tag der offenen Tür, wenn man noch dabei sein darf.
Die Argumentation des Staates ist ja die, naja, ist doch alles in Ordnung. Wir haben das ja geprüft und ihr könnt uns ja vertrauen. Ist doch alles in Ordnung.
Ja, und genau so ist es eben nicht. Sondern das Öffentlichkeitsprinzip heißt eben, dass jeder Wähler in der Lage sein soll zu überprüfen oder sich davon zu überzeugen, dass es bei der Wahl mit rechten Dingen zugeht.
Und wo steht das?
Das steht unter anderem im Bundeswahlgesetz. Und zwar steht da das Wort Öffentlichkeit, glaube ich, bis so rund 20 Mal drin an jeder Ecke. Und das wird abgeleitet aus dem Artikel 20 Grundgesetz. Da ist festgelegt, dass die Bundesrepublik ein demokratischer Rechtsstaat ist. Das heißt, Republik, Demokratie, Rechtsstaat sind da die drei Grundwerte, die da drin stehen. Und daraus leitet man im Allgemeinen ab, dass das staatliche Handeln öffentlich und transparent sein muss. Damit eine Kontrolle durch die Bürger stattfinden kann. Das heißt, das ist keine exotische Rechtsmeinung, die wir da vertreten haben, sondern das ist eigentlich Standard-Lehrbuchauffassung.
Was fordert denn das Gesetz? Viele sind, glaube ich, einfach nicht damit vertraut, was denn sozusagen eigentlich das Gesetz nun eigentlich tatsächlich sichergestellt sehen möchte bei einer Wahl.
Ja, da gibt es jetzt verschiedene Ebenen, die immer weiter konkretisieren. Da gibt es einmal das Grundgesetz, in dem einmal in Artikel 20 diese Sache mit Demokratie, Rechtsstaat und Republik festgelegt sind. Und dann gibt es den Artikel 38 Grundgesetz, der die fundamentalen Wahlprinzipien festlegt, nämlich, dass die Wahl frei ist und allgemein und geheim und direkt und allgemein. Und da kommt der Öffentlichkeit nicht vor, aber das Öffentlichkeitsprinzip wird halt, wie gesagt, aus diesem Artikel 20, das war sich aus dem demokratischen Rechtsstaat abgeleitet und genauso, wie anderes staatliches Handeln auch transparent sein muss, gilt das für die Wahl in ganz Besonderem, weil die Wahl eben der im Prinzip der Urakt der Legitimation im staatlichen Handeln ist.
Und die Delegation von Macht, die ja vom Volke aus geht?
Genau, die vom Volke aus geht. Das heißt, die Wahl ist also nichts, was von der Polizei organisiert wird, sondern das ist was, was die Bürger selber organisieren. Da hilft dann zwar der Staat mit seiner Verwaltung mit, aber das kommt dann im Prinzip auch durch die freiwilligen Wahllelfer zum Ausdruck, dass das wirklich eine Tätigkeit des Volkes ist, also das bürgerliches Handeln.
Und eigentlich die einzige, weil alle anderen Tätigkeiten sind dann delegiert.
Genau. Und da kann nicht der Staat hingehen oder die Regierung, Exekutive, und sagen, ja, lass mal gut sein, da kümmern wir uns schon drum. Das hat schon alles so seine Richtigkeit. Und das ist eigentlich genau der Unterschied zwischen einer Demokratie und so einem scheindemokratischen, autoritären Staat, wo es auch Abstimmungen gibt und wo das Innenministerium dann hinterher sagt, ja, ist alles gut gelaufen und unsere Wahlbehörden arbeiten vorbildlich.
Vielleicht nochmal auf diese Wahlprinzipien, weil das sind so, ja, das sind auch immer so Worte, die sind immer schnell gesagt, aber ich weiß nicht, ob sich jeder immer gleich auch was Konkretes darunter vorstellen kann. Also was heißt es zum Beispiel, dass die Wahl allgemein ist? Was heißt es, dass sie frei ist?
Ja, frei heißt, dass die Leute, die wahlberechtigt sind, ihre Stimme abgeben können, ohne äußeren Druck und sich wirklich frei entscheiden können.
Also frei im Sinne von freier Entscheidung, die unbeeinflusst ist von Leuten.
Genau. Das heißt, ich werde nicht unter Druck gesetzt und ich werde auch nicht, muss nicht hinterher Nachteile befürchten, weil ich mich so oder so entschieden habe. Das Prinzip der freien Wahl wird im Prinzip gesichert ganz wesentlich durch die geheime Wahl. Freie Wahl ist der Wert, um den es geht. Und die geheime Wahl ist sozusagen die organisatorische Art und Weise, wie ich das durchsetze, indem ich den Bürger ermögliche, seine Stimme so abzugeben, dass niemand sieht, wie die Stimme abgegeben wird.
Das ist sozusagen die Wahlkabine.
Das ist die Wahlkabine. Und wenn man davon ausgeht, dass man da alleine reingeht und dann nicht beobachtet wird, geht man davon aus, dass die Leute auch wirklich frei entscheiden können, weil eben niemand weiß, wie sie abgestimmt haben.
Und selbst wenn irgendjemand auf sie Druck ausübt, kann niemand feststellen, ob sie nun tatsächlich sich diesem Druck gebeugt haben oder nicht.
Der Wähler kann im Prinzip niemandem beweisen, wie er gewählt hat und ist deswegen dann auch nicht erst erpressbar.
Und was heißt, dass die Wahl allgemein ist?
Allgemein heißt, dass jeder wählen darf, jeder Bürger wählen darf. Das heißt, Frauen dürfen wählen und Männer dürfen wählen und unabhängig vom Alter, nicht unabhängig vom Alter, also ab 18. Aber es gibt keine Bevölkerungsgruppen, die mehr wählen oder weniger wählen. Da gibt es die Gleichheit, ich glaube, die haben wir vorhin bei der Aufzählung vergessen. Die bedeutet, dass jeder Wähler, oder jede Stimme, die abgegeben wird von einem Wähler, auch den gleichen Erfolgswert haben soll. Das heißt, es ist nicht so, dass jetzt die Stimmen von Leuten in Norddeutschland oder die Stimmen von Männern oder von Leuten mit blauen Augen mehr zählen als die von anderen. Jede Stimme zählt gleich, oder einigermaßen gleich. Einigermaßen gleich?
Das Problem sind an der Stelle wahrscheinlich die Wahlsysteme. Da können wir vielleicht noch mal drauf kommen.
Genau.
Und direkt? Direkt heißt, dass man das Gremium, das gewählt wird, tatsächlich auch direkt wählt. Das heißt, dass man nicht ein zwischengeschaltetes Gremium hat, das dann die eigentliche Wahl des Gremiums, das zu wählen ist, durchführt.
Aber da gibt es ja auch Ausnahmen.
Wir haben keine Wahlmänner wie in den USA. Der Präsident in den USA wird nicht direkt gewählt, sondern über so ein Wahlmännergremium, da wählt man die Wahlmänner.
Aber unser Bundespräsident wird doch auch über so ein Gremium bestimmt.
Genau, aber der Bundestag, und darum geht es in diesem Artikel 38 Grundgesetz, der wird direkt gewählt und da gibt es niemand mehr dazwischen, der sich da noch eine Meinung zu machen kann, was er jetzt mit seiner Stimme anfangen will.
Das heißt, das ist sozusagen das, was das Grundgesetz auslegt und was ja dann durch diese bekannte Papierwahl im Prinzip auch sichergestellt wird. Also dieses Prinzip des Wahllokals, um das herum nicht beworben werden darf, zumindest nicht am Wahltag, also das isoliert sozusagen.
Es gibt einige Maßnahmen im Wahllokal, die sich erstellen, dass tatsächlich frei gewählt werden kann. Dazu gehört, dass man eben nicht, wenn man da ins Wahllokal reinläuft, noch durch ein Spalier von Wahlwerbern laufen muss, dass im Wahllokal selber nicht geworben wird und auch nicht in einer gewissen Bannmeile um das Wahllokal herum. Dazu gehört auch, dass man nicht zu mehreren Leuten in die Wahlkabine gehen kann, damit man eben nicht beweisen kann oder Zeugen hat, wie man gewählt hat.
Jeder nur ein Kreuz.
Außer bei Kommunalwahlen, dann gibt es dann auch mal.
Jeder hat 70 Kreuze und da kann man dann einfach im Wahllokal tatsächlich sehen, dass diese Wahlprinzipien auch eingehalten werden. Die gleiche Wahl ist im Wahllokal jetzt noch nicht beobachtbar. Also höchstens dadurch, dass man tatsächlich, dass jeder nur eine Stimme abgeben kann. Das wirkt sich dann eher durch das Wahlsystem aus, wie sich Stimmen dann wirken auf die Sitzverteilung.
So, jetzt kommen aber die Wahlcomputer. Offensichtlich gibt es ja sozusagen verschiedene Diskussionsebenen. Die einen sind halt die, die unter dem Wahlprozess als Seuchen in irgendeiner Form zu leiden scheinen, die also diesen etablierten Vorgang, wie wir ihn jetzt gerade ansatzweise beschrieben haben, beklagen, dass er ineffektiv, arbeitsaufwendig und wie auch immer wäre. Und die jetzt sozusagen begrüßen, diese Wahlcomputer dort einzuführen und sich zahlreiche Vorteile davon versprechen, wie zum Beispiel, dass es einfacher sei, hört man immer wieder, dass es schneller auszuzählen sei und auch sicherer sei, was auch immer das heißen mag.
Also die Hauptgründe, die angeführt werden von den Beführer dann von Wahlcomputern, sind einmal die Zeitersparnis beim Auszählen. Das heißt die Einsparung von Wahlhelfern, die scheinbar so schwer zu beschaffen sind. Das war es dann auch schon. Es fällt immer schwer, mich da wieder neu einzudenken in diese Leute. Ist es denn so?
Also ich meine, ist es wirklich schwierig, Wahlhelfer zu bekommen? Ist das ein allgemein anerkanntes Problem oder hört man da nur Stimmen und die anderen schweigen?
Also ich habe natürlich jetzt noch nie die Gelegenheit gehabt, Wahlhelfer anzuwerben. Aber man hat nicht den Eindruck, dass in Gemeinden, in denen keine Wahlcomputer eingesetzt werden, jetzt die Durchfung der Wahl nicht mehr möglich ist, weil es keine Wahlhelfer gibt. Und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, gab es ja auch, nachdem der Wahlstift in Hamburg gescheitert ist, da eine Riesendiskussion, wie man jetzt die Wahl durchführen soll, weil man bei diesem neuen Kommunalwahlsystem in Hamburg eben so viele Stimmen hatte, die da ausgezählt werden mussten. Und da hatten sich ja offenbar auch einige Leute dann freiwillig gemeldet als Wahlhelfer und sind dann aber gar nicht hinzugekommen, weil der Ansturm der Freiwilligen da gar nicht zu bewältigen war. Ach, wollte ich.
Ich hatte das gar nicht mitbekommen.
Ich kenne da mehrere Leute, die da versucht hatten, oder sich freiwillig gemeldet hatten für die Auszählung der Wahl und dann aber nicht hinzugekommen sind. Statt Hamburg hat das Erfrischungsgeld, das man da als Wahlhelfer bekommt, auf 100 Euro hochgesetzt. Im meisten Gemeinsinn ist es 30 Euro. Und das hat offensichtlich dann gewirkt.
Und ich meine, im Vergleich zu der Anschaffungskosten von entsprechenden Wahlcomputern ist ja so 70 Euro mehr pro Wahlhelfer zwar immer noch eine Menge Geld, aber am Ende wahrscheinlich sogar noch billiger, oder?
Ja, vor allen Dingen billiger als die kommunalen Angestellten. Also in der Regel werden die, das hört man jedenfalls, dass die Wahlhelfer zum großen Teil rekrutiert werden aus dem öffentlichen Dienst. Und die können das dann aber sozusagen als Überstunden anrechnen. Das heißt, es gibt dann Freizeitausgleich. Das heißt, die werden natürlich dann als Wahlhelfer laufen die mit ihrem vollen Gehalt auf. Und das wird in der Regel sicherlich mehr als 30 Euro pro Tag sagen.
Das heißt, da kann sich sozusagen eine Gemeinde jetzt auch durchaus mal überlegen, ob das nicht am Ende die bessere Alternative ist, einfach preislich. Ich meine, 100 Euro, es gibt eine Menge Leute. Ich meine, was bedeutet das? Man muss da einen Tag lang von morgens um acht, neune anwesend sein, bis Walukar schließt. Also vielleicht so zehn Stunden. Trifft das so halbwegs, ne?
Ja, zehn Stunden ist die eigentliche Wahlhandlung. Das heißt, von acht bis 18 Uhr. Dann muss man kurz vorher da sein oder wenn man Wahlcomputer verwendet, auch ein bisschen vorher. Und dann dauert es eben so lange, dann bitte mal auszellen, wie es dauert. Das kann bei einer einfachen Bürgermeisterwahl, wo nur eine Stimme abzugeben ist, ziemlich schnell gehen. Also hier jetzt von einem halben Jahr an Kronenberg Bürgermeisterwahl, da war um 19 Uhr, glaube ich, das vorläufige Endergebnis da. Das heißt, da war dann alles komplett ausgezählt, inklusive Briefwählern, nach einer Stunde in allen Wahllokalen. Und bei komplizierteren Wahlen sieht das natürlich anders aus. Also hier in Hessen gibt es da ein relativ kompliziertes Kommunalwahlsystem, wo man so viele Stimmen hat, wie es Sitze im zu wählenden Gremium gibt. Das in Frankfurt, glaube ich, 85. Und wenn jeder 85 Stimmen verteilt, dann hat man was zu zählen.
Du hast an so einer Wahl auch schon mal teilgenommen. Wie ist das so? Ich habe an so einer Wahl noch nicht teilgenommen mit so vielen Stimmen. Wie kommt man sich da so vor, wenn man da in der Wahlkabine steht mit so einem langen Klopapier in der Hand?
Ja, dann steht da lauter Namen von Leuten, von denen man noch nie gehört hat, wenn man in einer größeren Stadt wohnt. Und dann macht man statt den 85 Stimmen, mit denen man eine Einzel verteilen kann, dann oben Listenkreuz bei der Partei.
Ach, das geht immer noch.
Das geht immer noch, ja. Aber was man so hört, wird das durchaus genutzt. Vor allen Dingen auch in kleineren Gemeinden, wo die Leute sich untereinander kennen. Und ich glaube, so im Landesdurchschnitt nutzt etwa jeder Zweite das Listenkreuz und die andere Hälfte verteilt die Stimmen individuell.
Es gibt da ja so eine Bewegung, mehr Demokratie, die ja, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ein ziemlicher Befürworter dieser Zählmethode ist, die auch, glaube ich, in Hamburg letztlich dahinter stand, bei der Einführung dieses neuen Systems, was dann sozusagen die Überlegung des Wahlstiftes nach sich zog. Was denkst du so über, ich meine, ihr habt euch ja sozusagen, hast ja gesagt, dein Vater hat sich schon immer damit beschäftigt. Ich denke, du wirst dich auch ein bisschen damit beschäftigt haben. Was denkst du über solche Systeme, die jetzt versuchen, diesen Anspruch mehr Demokratie, im Sinne von vorher war weniger da und jetzt haben wir mehr dadurch, dass wir fein granulierter abstimmen können. Passt das zusammen oder was denkst du darüber?
Ja, also erstmal muss man, glaube ich, sich angucken. Es gibt ja unterschiedliche Systeme, wo kumuliert und panaschiert wird.
Das ist der Begriff, kumulieren, panaschieren. Was heißt das andere?
Kumulieren heißt, ich kann einem Kandidaten mehr als eine Stimme geben. Panaschieren heißt, ich kann meine Stimmen verteilen auf mehrere Parteien oder Kandidaten von mehreren Parteien. Das heißt, hier entweder so ein Kommunalwahlsystem, wo kumuliert und panaschiert wird, da habe ich eine bestimmte Anzahl von Stimmen. In manchen Ländern mehr, in manchen weniger. In Hamburg zum Beispiel hat man, glaube ich, fünf Stimmen. Da kann ich jetzt diese fünf Stimmen entweder einem Kandidaten geben oder ich gebe fünf Kandidaten der gleichen Partei meine Stimme oder ich gebe die Stimmen beliebigen Kandidaten von beliebigen Parteien. Die Frage ist, ob wenn man statt mit fünf Stimmen 85 Stimmen hat, ob man dann tatsächlich einen stärkeren Einfluss auf die Zusammensetzung des Parlaments hat oder darauf, welche Leute jetzt aus einer bestimmten Partei ins Parlament einziehen. Denn es geht darum, dem Wähler einen Einfluss zu geben auf die Listenzusammensetzung der Partei, die er bevorzugt. Und da gibt es sicherlich Systeme, die effektiver sind und welche, die weniger effektiv sind. Und ich halte diese Masse von Stimmen, die man da verteilen muss, eigentlich für ein sehr ineffektives Wahlverfahren. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt noch mehr Stimmen zu verteilen hätte, als das zum Beispiel hier in Hessen der Fall ist, dann müsste ich ja irgendwann allen Kandidaten meiner Partei, wenn man da mal vorzugt, eine Partei, eine Stimme geben. Und dann wähle ich wieder nur die Liste. Also es ist ganz klar, es gibt da irgendwo einen Punkt zwischen wenig Stimmen, die ich verteilen kann und viel Stimmen, die ich verteilen kann, wo ich einen optimalen Hebel habe. Und es ist aber nicht so, dass viel da auch viel hilft.
Gibt es denn auch alternative Systeme, die auch wirklich in der Diskussion sind?
Es gibt in Deutschland glaube ich nicht, dass da zu kumulieren und panaschieren wirklich Alternativen diskutiert werden. Es gibt so ein System, das heißt Single Transferable Vote, wo man Präferenzen angeben kann. Das heißt, wenn der nicht erfolgreich ist, dann soll es der sein. Das sind aber auch Systeme, die relativ kompliziert auszählen sind.
Und vielleicht auch kompliziert zu verstehen.
Und auch kompliziert zu verstehen. Das denke ich auch bei diesen kumulierenden, panaschierenden Systemen mit sehr vielen Stimmen, dass da nicht so ohne Weiteres jedem transparent ist, was er tatsächlich tut, wenn er auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise wählt.
Ich denke Wahlsysteme und vor allem auch mal so eine genauere Analyse des Wahlsystems, wie wir es in Deutschland haben, mit all seinen Besonderheiten, mit Überhangmandaten und so weiter. Dass es halt auch noch mal genug Fleisch für einen eigenen Podcast. Ich würde jetzt ganz gerne nochmal zurückkommen zu den Wahlcomputern. Jetzt ist also klar, du schätzt sozusagen die Papierwahl als ein System, was die Prinzipien des Grundgesetzes zumindest, ja, also was offensichtlich diesen Prinzipien gerecht wird.
Das ist ein ziemlich robustes System, das sehr wenig störanfällig ist, weil allein schon durch die Organisationen der Wahl, mit den aus dem Volk rekrutierten Wahlvorständen, da es kaum möglich ist zu mauscheln. Denn nie ist jemand in einer Situation, wo er tatsächlich effektiv am Ergebnis was drehen kann. Das fängt an mit der dezentralen Organisation der Wahl. Das heißt, wenn man wirklich was bewegen will, wenn man wirklich am Ergebnis was verändern will, dann muss man großflächig auch Stimmen verschieben können. Dazu braucht man so viele Mitwisser, die sich aber alle gegeneinander kontrollieren, gegenseitig kontrollieren. Das ist praktisch nicht zu machen, ohne dass das aufliegt.
Das heißt, dieses immer wieder gehörte Argument mit na ja, auch bei Papierwahlen gibt es ja Wahlbetrug?
Auch bei Papierwahlen kann ich die ohne austauschen. Aber da sitzen dann fünf Wahlhelfer im Raum, die von unterschiedlichen Parteien kommen und die sich da schon sehr einig sein müssen bei dem Ziel, das sie damit erreichen wollen. Dann habe ich in einem Wahllokal, wo vielleicht 500 Leute abstimmen, ein anderes Ergebnis, das ja auch irgendwie noch so aussehen muss, dass das Ergebnis noch einigermaßen glaubwürdig bleibt.
Auch sozusagen die gefühlte Erwartung der Gemeinschaft, dass es der entspricht. Die Leute unterhalten sich natürlich auch darüber, was sie irgendwie schätzen und nicht schätzen.
Da können nicht plötzlich alle 500 Stimmen für die A-Partei sein oder die Masse der Stimmen. Vielleicht hat die A-Partei ja sowieso schon 30 Prozent der Stimmen bekommen. Das heißt, da kann ich dann sowieso nur noch 300 Stimmen verschieben. Und was habe ich dann erreicht? Dann habe ich das in einem Wahllokal gemacht. Und wenn meine fünf Leute zusammenhalten, dann bleibt es vielleicht auch unentdeckt.
Aber bei Wahlen, wo es jetzt nicht viele Wahllokale gibt, wenn das jetzt sozusagen so eine Bürgermeisterwahl in einer kleinen Gemeinde ist, da verteilt sich das ja dann nicht auf so viele Ohren.
Da verteilt sich das nicht auf so viele Ohren. Aber wenn sich dann die Wahllelfer tatsächlich so einig sind, dass sie alle den gleichen Kandidaten haben wollen, dann kann man fast vermuten, dass sich die Wähler vielleicht auch einig sind.
Dann gibt es sozusagen nicht viel zu fälschen. Ja, vielleicht zurück jetzt auf deinen Weg zum Verfassungsgericht. Du hast dich jetzt sozusagen damit auseinandergesetzt und fandest einfach den Gedanken, das Wahlcomputer einzuführen, bzw. die Tatsache, dass sie schon eingeführt waren, an manchen Stellen von Deutschland, nicht erträglich. Weil sozusagen du diese Grundprinzipien mit Wahlcomputern so nicht gewährleistet siehst. Richtig?
Genau. Und dann haben wir uns überlegt, was kann man dagegen machen?
Also vielleicht nochmal, warum eigentlich? Was ist jetzt an den Prinzipien frei, geheim, allgemein, direkt, was wird da missachtet?
Dazu muss man sich vielleicht angucken, wie so ein Wahlcomputer funktioniert. Aus Benutzersicht. Da hat man im Prinzip eine Wahlkabine, in der ein Bedienfeld von diesem Wahlcomputer installiert ist. Und da ist der Wahlzettel praktisch als Bedienoberfläche aufgedruckt auf so einem Schaltpult. Und da drückt man dann statt anzukreuzen auf Knöpfe. Und kriegt dann auch auf einem kleinen LCD angezeigt, wen man gewählt hat, drückt auf Stimmabgabe. Und dann wird die Stimme gespeichert. Und am Ende der Wahl legt der Wahlvorstand dann einen Schlüssel um. Und dann wird hinten auf der Rückseite des Gerätes, auf so einem kleinen Kassenzettel-Drucker, das Wahlergebnis ausgedruckt mit so einem Thermodrucker. Und das heißt, die Wähler geben ihre Stimmen im Geheimen ab in dieses Gerät. Das Gerät ist halt eine Kiste, wo eine Elektronik installiert ist und eine Software, auf der eine Software läuft. Und die macht halt irgendwas mit der Stimme, idealerweise speichert und zählt die, die die stimmen. Und gibt am Ende das Ergebnis aus. So sieht das idealerweise aus. Und Tatsache ist aber, dass man einfach nur eine geheime Eingabe hat und einen Prozess, den man nicht beobachten kann. Und am Ende kommt ein Ergebnis raus. Das heißt, man hat eine Information, die niemand gesehen hat, außer dem Wähler selber, die auf eine Art und Weise verarbeitet wird, die nicht beobachtet ist. Und hinterher kommt ein Ergebnis raus, das dann einfach nicht überprüfbar ist. Da kann man sich auf den Kopf stellen, das Ergebnis ist dann halt das Ergebnis, das rauskommt. Und das sollte das Richtige sein. Aber das hängt letztendlich davon ab, ob der Prozess, der da abläuft in dem Gerät, richtig funktioniert. Und das ist ja im Prinzip genau das Gegenteil von einem Öffentlichkeitsprinzip, wo jeder sehen kann, dass die Stimmen richtig verarbeitet werden. Das heißt, bei einer Papierwahl, da kann ich den ganzen Tag in einem Wahllokal rumhängen, wenn ich nichts Besseres zu tun habe, und zusehen, dass die ohne tatsächlich intakt bleibt, dass da keiner dran rumfummelt. Ich kann sehen, wie die nach der Wahl ausgeschüttet wird und wie die Stimmen dann ausgezählt werden. Und ich kann den Wahlhelfern dabei über die Schulter gucken und einfach mich davon überzeugen, dass das alles seine Richtigkeit hat.
Aber die Urne sozusagen ist ja der Wahlcomputer dann auch selber, und die Urne steht sozusagen die ganze Zeit in der Kabine.
Genau, die Urne ist der Wahlcomputer. Und das Entscheidende ist eigentlich die Frage, wenn ich auf den Knopf drücke, Stimmabgabe, was passiert dann mit meiner Stimme? Wird die dann so abgespeichert wie angezeigt, oder wird da was anderes abgespeichert? Oder wird vielleicht auch gar nichts abgespeichert, sondern vielleicht werden die Stimmen auch erst am Ende der Wahl alle geschrieben, wenn man gezählt hat, wie viele Weller auf den Knopf gedrückt haben. Und das kann man nicht beobachten. Und damit liefert man sich im Prinzip den Leuten aus, die diese Wahlcomputer bauen und warten oder Zugriff haben auf diese Wahlcomputer.
Ja, aber die sagen natürlich irgendwie, wieso ist doch alles geprüft, hat die PTB sicher alles durchgelesen und hat gesagt, das ist alles super.
Ja, und das mag auch sein, dass die alle integer sind, aber darauf kommt es nicht an. Es kommt darauf an, dass es denen nicht zusteht, diese Kontrolle des Volkes sozusagen zu unterbinden. Und das ist das, was da passiert. Und das ist einfach ein erheblicher Eingriff in die Architektur der Demokratie. Es macht einen Riesenunterschied, ob das Volk sich davon überzeugen kann, dass die Wahl vernünftig abläuft oder ob das Innenministerium und die PTB bestätigen, dass das schon alles seine Richtigkeit hat. Und mit der gleichen Logik, man könnte sozusagen diese Verantwortung delegieren an die PTB oder auch an die Wahlbehörden, könnte man auch die Auszählung der Papierstimmen an den Postdienstleister verteilen.
Du hast also jetzt beschlossen, dass es sozusagen Zeit ist, da auch mal konkret was zu unternehmen. Was waren denn so die ersten konkreten Schritte, nachdem du da 2005 auf das Thema gestoßen bist, die du unternommen hast?
Ja, wir haben überlegt, was man dagegen machen kann, ob man das verhindern kann vor der Wahl. Da war natürlich jetzt nur noch relativ viel Zeit. Ich glaube, dieser Artikel kam im August raus und die Wahl war ja schon dann Ende September. Wir sind dann aber relativ schnell, es ist klar geworden, wir reden von der letzten Bundestagswahl 2005, wir sind relativ schnell dahinter gekommen, dass man eigentlich vor der Wahl präventiv nichts machen kann. Jedenfalls nicht auf dem Rechtsweg. Eine politische Lösung war ja im Prinzip keine Zeit. Es ist also so, dass man als Bürger wahlrechtliche Regelungen oder auch wahlorganisatorische Maßnahmen nicht von vorneherein angreifen kann. Es gibt da keine Rechtsmittel dagegen, sondern das Kind muss erst in den Brunnen fallen. Dann gibt es den Weg des Wahleinspruchs, den man beim Wahlprüfungsausschuss des Bundestages einlegt. Da kann dann geprüft werden, ob das ein Wahlfehler war und ob der Ergebnis relevant war. Aber der Fehler muss erst mal gemacht werden. Das muss erst mal gegen irgendwelche Rechtsprinzipien verstoßen werden, bevor man sich dagegen wehren kann. Das ist natürlich eine blöde Regelung, weil es dann auch automatisch zu diesen Abwehrreaktionen kommt. Das gewählte Gremium, in dem Fall der Bundestag, entscheidet, ob das so richtig war oder nicht. Das heißt, die Leute, die gewählt sind, müssen dann sagen, wir sind zwar gewählt, aber irgendwie auch unrechtmäßig.
Wir gehen einmal.
Und da kann man sich ja überlegen, wie wahrscheinlich das ist, dass so etwas dann Erfolg hat.
Meinst du, es wäre eine gute Idee, dass man vielleicht auch mal eine gesetzliche Regelung nachdenkt, die quasi schon im Vorfeld die Möglichkeit bietet hier. Da zeichnet sich ein Wahlmodus ab, der unserer Auffassung nach nicht was auch immer entspricht. Also auch wenn es gegen das Wahlgesetz verstoßen würde, sozusagen, offensichtlich gibt es keine Rechtsmittel. Oder bezieht sich das jetzt nur auf so eine verfassungsrechtliche, grundsätzliche Ebene?
Ich glaube, es gibt keine Rechtsmittel. Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel jemand hingehen würde und die Wahlbenachrichtigung nur noch an Männer verschickt und nicht mehr an Frauen, ich glaube nicht, dass man dagegen tatsächlich im Vorfeld rechtlich vorgehen kann. Aber in diesem drastischen Beispiel kann man natürlich davon ausgehen, dass dann andere Reaktionen erfolgen würden. Aber wenn es um so Sachen sind, die dann eher umstritten sind, dann muss man dann tatsächlich erst mal abwarten, dass das tatsächlich stattfindet.
Das habt ihr also dann gemacht. Die Wahl hat 2005 stattgefunden. Und danach hast du eine Beschwerde eingelegt.
Und danach habe ich und mein Vater auch einen Wahleinspruch beim Bundestag angelegt. Und da denkt man dann, wenn man... Also für uns war eigentlich klar, dass das so nicht geht mit den Wahlcomputern. Also das war für uns so offensichtlich, dass das so nicht sein kann, dass diese öffentliche Kontrolle wegfällt. Dass wir eigentlich auch naiv genug waren, zu glauben, dass den Bundestag oder den Wahlprüfungsausschuss des Bundestages das irgendwie interessieren würde. Aber aus den Gründen, die ich eben schon genannt habe, war das eher nicht der Fall. Hatte ich den Eindruck.
Was war denn dann die Argumentation?
Dann kam eigentlich erst mal das Bundesinnenministerium. Also vom Ablauf her läuft das so, dass der Wahlprüfungsausschuss dann Stellungnahmen einholt, je nachdem, was für Wahlfehler da akmoniert werden. Entweder von dem Kreiswahlleiter der betroffenen Gemeinde oder in unserem Fall, wo es ja um rechtliche Regelungen geht, dann vom Bundeswahlleiter oder auch vom Innenministerium. Und das Innenministerium hat dann Stellung genommen in einem Schriftsatz, 25 Seiten oder sowas, wo die dann beschrieben haben, wie toll das eigentlich alles ist mit den Wahlcomputern und wie sicher das ist und wie sicher die aufbewahrt werden und dass man die sowieso nicht manipulieren kann, weil man ja den Quellcode nicht hat, weil der Quellcode ja nur bei der Physikal-Technischen Bundesanstalt und beim Hersteller vorliegt und weil man auch keinen Zugang zu den Geräten hat und weil der Wahlvorstand vor der Wahl ein umfangreiches Sammelsurium von Prüfmaßnahmen durchführt, bei der sowieso jede Manipulation erkennbar wäre. Und außerdem müsste man ja, um Stimmen zu verschieben von Partei A nach Partei B, schon vorher wissen, welche Partei auf welchem Knopf ist. Und weil die Geräte erst kurz vor der Wahl konfiguriert würden, welche Partei dann auf welcher Taste liegt, sei das praktisch völlig auszuschließen, so eine Manipulation, weil das Zeitfenster für die Manipulation zu klein wäre. Und ja, dann hat der Bundestag diese Stellungnahme noch eine ganze Weile liegen lassen. Da kam dann auch in diese Zeit der NEDAP-Hack rein.
Also für die Leute, die die Sendung jetzt noch nicht gehört haben, der NEDAP-Hack war sozusagen jetzt ausgehend von Holland. Das heißt, dieses mit dem deutschen Modell nahezu baugleiche Gerät. Also es wird natürlich vom Hersteller bestritten, dass es wie ähnlich wäre, aber es ist de facto nahezu dasselbe Gerät. Also technisch gibt es da keine nennenswerten Unterschiede. Das wurde dann eben auseinandergenommen. Das war so eine Kooperation der holländischen und deutschen Hacker. Und dadurch wurden einfach zahlreiche Methoden aufgezeigt, wie man das Gerät dann doch auf die eine und die andere Art und Weise mühelos manipulieren kann. Das kam dann...
Das kam da rein. Und das heißt, da wurden also doch die eine oder andere Tatsachenbehauptung des Innenministeriums aus dem Schriftsatz da ganz klar widerlegt, insbesondere was die Manipulierbarkeit der Geräte angeht. Und da hat aber weder die Physikalische und Technische Bundesanstalt, noch das BMI sich offenbar genötig gesehen, da nochmal was nachzuschieben. Und der Bundestag hat sich auch nicht davon abhalten lassen, dann noch drei Monate später dann im Prinzip das Gegenteil zu beschließen. Es gab dann also... Es läuft dann so in den Verfahren, dass der Wahlprüfungsausschuss dann eine Entschließungsvorlage vorbereitet. Die wird dann vom Bundestag beschlossen. Und darin werden dann die Wahleinsprüche zurückgewiesen. Und in dieser Beschlussvorlage, die da uns betrifft, die Wahlcomputer, da ist also beschlossen worden vom Bundestag, dass die Geräte also eben nicht manipuliert werden können.
Das hat der Bundestag mit seiner geballten Kompetenz festgestellt.
Genau, in seiner unendlichen Weisheit. Und dann waren wir eben durch mit dem Bundestag. Und dann kommt die nächste Stufe, gibt es eine Revisionsinstanz, und das ist das Verfassungsgericht. Und dieser Einspruch gegen den Beschluss des Bundestages in der Wahlprüfungssache ist dann die sogenannte Wahlprüfungsbeschwerde. Und das ist das, was wir dann beim Verfassungsgericht gemacht haben.
Was muss man dazu vorlegen? Ich glaube, beim Verfassungsgericht, da schlägt ja so einiges auf. Keine Ahnung, wie viele Anfragen die so jedes Jahr bekommen, um irgendwas zu prüfen.
Ich glaube, die haben ungefähr 6000 Verfahrenseingänge im Jahr. Und davon sind aber natürlich die wenigsten Sachen Wahlsachen. Ich glaube, von den etwa 200 Wahleinsprüchen beim Bundestag in dieser Legislaturperiode ab 2005 sind dann anschließend zehn an das Verfassungsgericht gegangen. Und die anderen Themen, die da noch aufgelaufen sind, waren, glaube ich, dieses negative Stimmgewicht, das ja auch vom Verfassungsgericht positiv beschieden worden ist, letzten Sommer.
Was heißt das?
Das ist diese Geschichte, die in Dresden in Laborbedingungen aufgetreten ist, weil da später gewählt werden konnte erst. Da treten Situationen auf, wo eine Partei, die mehr Stimmen bekommt, plötzlich einen Sitz verliert. Also die CDU durfte in Dresden nur höchstens, weiß ich nicht, so viel 40.000 Stimmen bekommen, sonst hätte sie im Bundestag einen Sitz verloren.
Das ist dieser Fall mit der verstorbenen NPD-Kandidatin.
Das war ein Thema beim Verfassungsgericht. Dann gibt es noch Sachen, die mit Überhangsmandaten zusammenhängen und mit der Listenverbindung WASG und WDS. Und eben Wahlcomputer.
Was musstet ihr denn dafür tun? Da kann man ja nicht sich mal einen Abend hinsetzen und mal locker handschriftlich so ein paar wir finden das scheiße-Sätze schreiben. Sondern da muss man ja dann auch gut beraten sein und etwas Belastbares hinbringen.
Formal kann man durchaus da auch einen schlecht formulierten Schriftsatz hinschicken. Man braucht auch keinen Anwalt. Mein Vater hat auch zunächst keinen Anwalt genommen. Aber man braucht 100 Unterschriften von Wählern oder von Personen, die wahlberechtigt waren bei der Bundestagswahl und die das unterstützen. Da sind wir offenbar ja offene Türen eingerannt. Wir mussten da auch gar nicht rumlaufen, sondern da haben uns Leute pausenlos Unterschriften nach Hause geschickt. Wir hatten dann noch 800 dann am Ende, oder 850 oder so was. Da gab es offenbar, ohne dass wir da weiter groß Werbung machen mussten, ordentlichen Bedarf, dass sowas passiert.
Also ihr hattet auf jeden Fall schon mal auch das klare Signal, ihr seid da nicht alleine mit eurer Skepsis.
Ja, das hatten wir ohnehin schon durch die Wahlcomputer-Petition von Tobias Hahn bekommen. Tobias Hahn ist ein Mathematiker aus Berlin und der hat, wann war das, 2006? Ich glaube im Herbst 2006, eine Petition, eine Internetpetition beim Bundestag abgegeben, die sich gegen den Paragrafen 35 Bundeswahlgesetz richtet. Und genau dieser Paragraf lässt den Einsatz von Wahlgeräten zu. Da steht also drin, Wahlgeräte dürfen eingesetzt werden unter den und den Bedingungen. Und Tobias Hahn hat gesagt, lieber Petitionsausschuss, schafft den Paragrafen ab. Wir wollen keinen Wahlcomputer mehr. Und da haben dann innerhalb der Zeichnungsfrist, da kann man im Internet diese Petition dann unterschreiben, mit seinem Namen und seiner Adresse innerhalb der sechswöchigen Zeichnungsfrist haben da 45.000 Leute mitgezeichnet. Und das war dann zu dem Zeitpunkt, glaube ich, die zweiterfolgreichste Petition. Das ist, glaube ich, auch immer noch einen der erfolgreichsten überhaupt. Obwohl es jetzt schon eine Weile her ist. Und 45.000 Leute sind ja schon mehr als zwei. Also da hat das Thema dann eigentlich auch zum ersten Mal in der Presse einen größeren Widerhall gefunden.
Und über diesen Hack hinaus, was ja immer sowas lustiges, hahaha, da hat mal wieder jemand eine Büchse aufgemacht, aber dann verheilt es halt schnell. Aber hier wurde dann schon klar, dass es einfach auch ein gesellschaftliches Interesse gibt.
Genau. Also wir hatten nie den Eindruck, dass wir da irgendwie Einzelkämpfer sind, die mit irgendeiner spinnenden Idee oder irgendwelchen exotischen Rechtsmeinungen mal was versuchen, sondern es gab viele Leute, denen das Thema im Herzen lag. Ich habe auch immer wieder E-Mails bekommen zu dem Thema von Leuten, die ich nie vorher getroffen oder gesehen habe, denen das Thema im Herzen lag.
Aber ihr habt euch dann doch einen Anwalt genommen, über kurz oder lang?
Ich habe mich dann dazu entschlossen, das so professionell wie möglich anzugehen beim Verfassungsgericht. Denn man hat da im Prinzip nur einen Schuss. Das heißt, wenn man es vergeigt, dann hat man es vergeigt.
Damit verhindert man sozusagen, dass das andere dann noch ankommt?
Genau, dann ist das sozusagen präjurisiert. Das war einfach nicht wünschenswert. Also das musste einfach gut gehen. Und da habe ich dann zwei Leute gefunden, die da gut draufgepasst haben, sagen das Till Jäger. Das ist ein Anwalt aus Berlin, der ziemlich viel auch in Sachen Open Source unterwegs ist. Und der ja sozusagen die nötige Computer-Affinität mitgebracht hat. Ich glaube, Till sagt auch solche Sachen wie, man muss auch mal programmiert haben, ein paar Zeilen, um zu wissen, was da passiert in so einem Computer. Also der ist wirklich technikaffin und gut für die Schnittstelle IT und Computer. Und der andere, den wir angesprochen haben, war Ulrich Karben. Das ist ein Professor für Staatsrecht. Das heißt, das ist einer, der spezialisiert ist auf diese ganzen staatsrechtlichen Fragen, Öffentlichkeit, Wahlruhmsätze. Und der dann auch sozusagen die Aura, das Staatstragen damit bringt, um da auch was umgehört zu werden.
Ja, und auch vor allem, um so formulieren zu können, dass man auch wirklich bei den Leuten ankommt, die jetzt dieses Wissen und auch dieses Verständnis vielleicht auch erst mal nicht haben. Ja, das heißt, ihr habt das dann eingereicht. Wann wurde das eigentlich eingereicht?
Der Bundestag hat unseren Einspruch zurückgewiesen kurz vor Weihnachten 2006. Und dann hat man zwei Monate Zeit, Beschwerde dagegen einzulegen beim Verfassungsgericht. Wenn dann die Weihnachtsferien erst mal rum sind, hat man noch sechs Wochen. Also es ist nicht so viel Zeit. Und wir haben aber das Thema dann fachlich aufgeteilt zwischen uns dreien und gleichzeitig geschrieben. Was die Technischen Sachen habe ich gemacht. Till hat so die einfachrechtlichen Sachen gemacht und das alles zusammen gebastelt. Und Karpen hat die staatstheoretischen Geschichten dazu beigetragen. Und das hat sehr gut geklappt.
Was kommt dann dabei raus? So 100 Seitenstapeln oder was?
100 Seiten und hunderte Seiten Anlagen. Und das ist also wirklich ein Päckchen gewesen, das dann nach Karlsruhe gegangen ist.
Schickt man sowas mit der Post oder geht man da irgendwie selber hin und legt ihn das auf den Tisch?
Das hat der Till Jaeger mit einem Kurier gemacht. Aber ich glaube, das schickt man nicht mit der Post. Ja, und dann war sehr schnell klar, dass das Gericht die Sache ernst nimmt. Denn die haben innerhalb von sechs Wochen die Klage weitergeleitet zur Stellungnahme an Bundestag, Innenministerium, Physikalische Energie, Bundesanstalt und auch an den CCC.
Das ist schnell?
Das ist schnell, ja. Zum Beispiel schnell verglichen mit dem Bundestag, wo die Sachen einfach erst mal sechs Wochen, drei Monate liegen bleiben, bevor da irgendwas passiert.
Aber ich meine, das ist auch schnell fürs Verfassungsgericht.
Das ist auch schnell fürs Verfassungsgericht. Also ich hatte dann auch inzwischen Kontakt gefunden zu Leuten, die vorher schon mal sowas gemacht hatten. Die Leute von wahlrecht.de, die auch das Verfahren beim Verfassungsgericht schon ganz gut kannten und die meinten, der Standardfall, wenn das also vom Verfassungsgericht nicht für aussichtsreich gehalten wird, läuft so ab, dass man dann irgendwann vom Berichterstatter, also von dem Richter, der sich damit auseinandersetzt, einen sogenannten Bedenkenbrief bekommt, in dem der Berichterstatter schildert, warum er glaubt, dass es nicht aussichtsreich ist. Und da kann man dann noch mal drauf reagieren. Und dann entscheidet so ein Dreiergremium aus drei Richtern. Dann beschließt er dann ohne weitere Gründung mit Verweis auf diesen Bedenkenbrief, dass das abgelehnt ist. Und da werden dann in der Regel auch noch nicht mal Stellungnahmen eingeholt von irgendjemandem. Und also allein die Tatsache, dass dieser Bedenkenbrief ausblieb und dass da bei aller Welt Gutachten oder Stellungnahmen eingeholt wurden, das war schon Hinweis darauf, dass das nicht im Sande verläuft.
Das ist ja auch wirklich ein richtiges Verfassungsthema.
Es ist eigentlich Butter und Brot für einen Staatsrechtler, möchte man meinen. Es sollte eigentlich auch Butter und Brot sein für das Innenministerium, dass er das Verfassungsministerium ist. Aber den Eindruck hattest du nicht. Den Eindruck hatte ich nicht. Es sollte eigentlich auch ein Thema sein, das den Bundestag sehr interessiert, denn es geht ja letztendlich um die Legitimation des Bundestages und darum, ob Zweifel aufkommen können, ob der Bundestag richtig zusammengesetzt ist. Das hat man eigentlich ganz gut gesehen bei dieser Bush-Florida-Geschichte. Jetzt ganz unabhängig, ob man jetzt der Meinung ist, dass da gedreht worden ist oder ob die Wahlcomputer in den USA zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt manipuliert waren oder nicht, ist auf jeden Fall so, dass das Ergebnis auf jeden Fall denunzierbar war in den USA.
Die Glaubwürdigkeit sozusagen, eine Delegitimation.
Genau, die Glaubwürdigkeit vom Bush war praktisch in seiner kompletten Amtszeit ständig dadurch beeinträchtigt, dass die Legitimität seiner Wahl oder das Zustandekommen des Wahlergebnisses angezweifelt werden konnte. Wenn man dann solche Wahlcomputer benutzt, wo das Ergebnis nicht überprüfbar ist, da kann man gegen solche Delegitimationen eben auch nichts machen. Da kann man die Geräte vorher noch so sicher aufbewahren und sich noch so sicher sein, dass die richtig zählen. Man kann einfach nicht beweisen, dass das Ergebnis, das da rausgekommen ist, tatsächlich auch stimmt.
Und dann kann halt jeder denken, was er will.
Und dann kann jeder denken, was er will. Und deswegen ist es eigentlich durchaus im Sinne des Bundestages, dass sowas eben nicht passiert, sondern dass man Wahlverfahren hat, das überprüfbar ist und wo im Zweifelsfall man sagen kann, okay, dann zählen wir eben nochmal nach.
Was gab es denn so für Reaktionen aus dem Bundestag? Also ich meine, ist das jetzt wirklich so, dass das komplett ignoriert wurde und alle andere Meinung waren? Oder gab es da auch, wenn auch nur vereinzelte Stimmen, die jetzt diesen Vorgang, irgendwelche Aufmerksamkeit oder Wohlwollen gezeugt haben?
Also der Bundestag selber hat die Wahleinsprüche ja zusammen mit anderen einstimmig abgelehnt. Das heißt... Einstimmig heißt, dass da...
Niemand dagegen gestimmt hat.
Dass niemand dagegen gestimmt hat.
Keiner.
Man muss sich das so vorstellen, dass der Bundestag in seinen Sitzungswochen ja nicht immer bis auf den letzten Platz besetzt ist, sondern die haben dann auch noch andere Baustellen und Ausschusssitzungen und kommen eigentlich nur zu den großen Debatten oder zu den großen Abstimmungen da in Vollerzahn. Bei dem Tagesgeschäft, und dazu gehört auch eben das Abhügeln von Wahleinsprüchen, da ist dann nur eine kleine Besetzung im Bundestag. Und in dem Fall von unseren Wahleinsprüchen waren also, glaube ich, ungefähr 40 Leute im Plenum und das kann man also sehen im Parlamentsfernsehen, das gibt es als Video-On-Demand. Und das wird dann zur Abstimmung aufgerufen und dann heben alle die Hand und dann ist das eben einstimmig angenommen.
Also man hat nicht wirklich den Eindruck, dass man sich da groß inhaltlich ausnahmt. Aber jetzt unabhängig von dieser Abstimmung und dem Widerspruch, ich meine, das hast du ja auch schon gesagt, das ist irgendwie absurd. Da hat man irgendwie ein gewähltes Gremium, das sozusagen jetzt in Macht gekommen ist. Und dann soll es irgendwie ein paar Monate später darüber abstimmen, ob es vielleicht nicht legitimiert ist. Muss man nicht lange darüber nachdenken, dass das irgendwie auch ein bisschen absurd ist. Trotz alledem, so läuft das nun mal, aber gab es jetzt in dem Moment, wo das Verfassungsgericht begonnen hat, die Arbeit aufzunehmen und auch den Bundestag quasi um Stellung, ist das so, also auch der Bundestag und das Innenministerium, wer wurde nochmal alles auf?
Das ging an den Bundestag, den Bundesrat, die Bundesregierung vertreten durch das Innenministerium, die physikal-technische Bundesanstalt, den Bundeswahlleiter und die Landesregierung. Ach ja, und an die Fraktionen im Bundestag.
Auch noch.
Und Stellung genommen haben aber nur das Innenministerium und die physikal-technische Bundesanstalt.
Sonst keiner.
Keine Fraktion. Der Bundesrat zum Beispiel mischt sich nicht ein in die Bundestagsangelegenheiten. Der hat dann auch formell beschlossen, dass er sich nicht Stellung nimmt. Der Bundestag hat auch nicht Stellung genommen. Ob es dann Beschlüsse gibt, weiß ich nicht. Aber auf jeden Fall haben die nicht Stellung bezogen. Auch die Fraktionen haben keine Stellung bezogen. Es haben einige Landesregierungen kurze Schriftsetze geschickt. Das Land Rheinland-Pfalz hat darum gebeten, dass man das klipp und klar klärt, ob diese Öffentlichkeitsproblematik ein Problem ist oder nicht. Das war eigentlich das einzige Fingeraufzeigen von einer Regierung, die gesagt hat, wir wollen das wissen.
Das Land Rheinland-Pfalz hat auch relativ viele Wahlcomputer im Einsatz.
Das Land Rheinland-Pfalz hat Wahlcomputer im Einsatz, aber viele wäre jetzt, glaube ich, übertrieben. In Koblenz gibt es welche, und ich glaube, das war es dann aber auch.
Wo ist die stärkste Dichte? In Nordrhein-Westfalen?
Ja, in Nordrhein-Westfalen ist auf jeden Fall der große Anwender.
Aber die hat das nicht interessiert. Die hat das nicht interessiert. Ich meine, gab es dann sozusagen jetzt aus dem politischen Umfeld, unabhängig davon, dass die Fraktionen als solche nicht Stellung genommen haben, ist das einer, aber hat irgendjemand den Kontakt gesucht?
Nein, Kontakt hat keiner gesucht. Und es hat eigentlich auch niemand die Öffentlichkeit gesucht. Solange das noch nicht wirklich in die mögliche Verhandlung ging, war das kein Thema, das in der Presse auch sehr stark stattgefunden hat. Und es gab auch keine Abgeordneten, die sich da intensiv mit auseinandergesetzt haben. Wenn man mal absieht von dieser Petitionsgeschichte, da musste sich der Petitionsausschuss oder der Petitionsausschuss hat sich damit beschäftigt. Und da gab es auch eine Sitzung des Petitionsausschusses, in dem das Gegenstand war. Und da wurde auch engagiert darüber diskutiert.
Warst du da?
Da war ich nicht, aber das konnte man auch wieder im Parlamentsfernsehen sehen. Mein Vater war da. Und das war schon interessant, wie die Abgeordneten da auch das Innenministerium, oder kritische Fragen, das Innenministerium gestellt haben. Aber dann ist es doch irgendwie im Sand verlaufen. Also die haben dann doch letztendlich dann anschließend einen Beschluss verfasst, der sich dann wieder orientierte an diese Ablehnung des Wahlanspruches inhaltlich. Also es ist schon alles sicher, aber wir übergeben das mal dem Innenministerium für seine Akten, damit die...
Ich meine, fühlt man sich da irgendwie überhaupt noch ernst genommen?
Ja, das hat mich jetzt nicht überrascht. Also wir waren dann letztendlich dann zu der Zeit auch schon mal im Verfassungsgericht und eine Stufe weiter und da wurden wir auch ernst genommen, offensichtlich, wie man abwesen konnte, aus den Informationen, die die eingeholt haben. Und dann hat mich das zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht mehr so gestört.
Jetzt gab es ja, also als erstes wurden Stellungnahmen eingeholt, das Innenministerium hat geantwortet, die PTB hat geantwortet.
Besonders ausführlich hat die PTB geantwortet. Und die haben eben nochmal ihr Prüfkonzept vorgestellt und erklärt, warum aus ihrer Sicht die Geräte sicher sind, weil die nämlich zwar vielleicht technisch nicht so sicher sind, aber sicher genug, wenn sie eingebettet sind in ein organisatorisches Verfahren, wo die Geräte eben unter Verschluss sind und wo nicht jedermann an die Geräte rankommt und wo die Geräte versiegelt werden und wo man eben die Geräte im Kontext des Verfahrens sehen müsste. Ich habe sehr argumentiert über die Schiene, das ist sicher. Meine PTB ist jetzt auch keine Gesellschaft, wo Juristen sitzen, die sich mit wahlrechtlichen Themen auseinandersetzen, sondern das sind eben Leute mit einem technischen Hintergrund und die setzen sich mit dem technischen Thema Sicherheit oder Nichtsicherheit auseinander. Das Innenministerium hat argumentiert, dass die Geräte eben nicht nur sicher sei, sondern auch, dass die Öffentlichkeit eigentlich so nicht gefordert sei bei Wahlen mit Wahlgeräten. Denn die Geräte seien ja sicher und deswegen sei auch das Ergebnis, das ihnen rauskommt, richtig. Und deswegen sei da die Öffentlichkeit eben nicht so gefordert. Und die sei auch in einem anderen Zusammenhang eingeschränkt. Denn zum Beispiel würde die Öffentlichkeit ja seine Grenzen haben bei der Geheimheit der Stimmabgabe. Und die Öffentlichkeit würde ihre Grenzen haben bei der Briefwahl, wo man ja auch nicht zusehen kann, wie die Stimmen abgegeben und versandt und gelagert werden. Und das wäre auch bei Wahlgeräten hinzunehmen. Und im Übrigen haben die halt sich gar nicht so umfangreich geäußert, sondern einfach den Schriftsatz vom Bundestag nochmal als Anlage beigelegt. Und das war es dann eigentlich.
Der CTC hat sich auch geäußert.
Ja, da kannst du vielleicht viel besser...
Ich war da selber nicht dran beteiligt, aber du hast es ja schon gesagt, aber da ist halt auch umfangreiches Material bereitgestellt worden. Aber im Prinzip gab es nur diese drei Stellungnahmen dann?
Es gab im Prinzip nur diese drei Stellungnahmen. Der CTC hat sich ja relativ umfangreich geäußert. Ich glaube, es sind 50 Seiten gewesen. Und ein Gutachten über die technische Sicherheit der Geräte.
Was ja auch veröffentlicht wurde.
Was auch veröffentlicht wurde, wo es auch ein schönes Video dazu gab, wo die Software in einer Mute getauscht wird, obwohl Rob noch nicht mal einen Akkuschrauber genommen hat.
Das ging auch noch schneller sozusagen.
Das glaube ich, da könnte man noch optimieren. Aber man kann eigentlich ganz gut sehen an dem Video, dass man wirklich, wenn man Zugriff auf physikalischen Zugriff hat, auf die Geräte und eine Software verfügbar hat, die Stimmen verschiebt, dass man auch eine größere Zahl von Geräten in sehr kurzer Zeit einfach umsockeln kann, weil einfach die Geräte, die Software auf Airbroms drauf ist, die gesockelt sind. Und die man eben ruckzuck getauscht hat. Und weil die Geräte eben auch nicht auf dem neuesten Stand der Technik sind, sondern im Prinzip auf Atari-Niveau, eine alte Motorola-Technik, sind da auch heutige Software-Austausch-Verhinderungsverfahren, wie man das aus der Xbox kennt oder aus dem Handy, eben einfach da nicht vorhanden. Da läuft drauf, was man reinsteckt. Und das kann man eben ganz gut sehen. Und das hat offensichtlich die Argumentation des Innenministeriums oder auch der PTB, dass das schon alles sicher genug ist, doch erheblich beschädigt, würde ich mal sagen.
Nach den Stellungnahmen, was ist denn da als nächstes passiert? Es gab doch auch eine öffentliche Anhörung.
Ja, es gab dann jetzt im Oktober auch eine öffentliche Anhörung. Und ich habe den Eindruck, dass die Gegenseite, das heißt physikalische Bundesanstalt und Innenministerium, das doch unterschätzt haben. Denn die wurden da ganz schön überfahren.
Wie läuft das da ab? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Wir waren auch nicht da. Verfassungsgericht, was ist das? Große Hallen, kleine Raum?
Verfassungsgericht ist ein Nachkriegsgebäude, sehr hell. Licht von zwei Seiten, Glas und Beton. Und da gibt es einen Gerichtssaal für, ich würde mal schätzen, 250 Leute passen da rein. Und vorne am Stirnende ist die Richterbank. Da sitzen die sechs Richter. Und davor sind zwei Reihen Tische, an denen die beteiligten Parteien sitzen. Jetzt aus Sicht des Publikums auf der rechten Seite sitzt, oder bei uns war das so, saßen die Beschwerdeführer, das ist wir mit unseren Anwälten. Und auf der linken Seite saßen die Leute vom Innenministerium und vom Bundeswahlleitern, von der PTB und die Sachverständigen. Und dann gibt es da hinterher ein Stuhl für das Publikum. Und dann kommt der Senat rein, muss mal aufstehen. Dann, wenn die sich hingesetzt haben, gibt es eine kleine Einführung ins Thema, lesen die vor, wer alles erschienen ist. Da muss dann jeder wieder aufstehen, der gerade vorgelesen wird, dessen Name gerade erscheint. Und dann hat der Vorsitzende des Senats dann eine Einführung ins Thema gemacht, zusammen mit dem Berichterstatter. Und da wurde dann schon einiges angesprochen, was darauf hindeutete, dass das Gericht doch Sympathien für unser Anliegen hat. Also da wurde erwähnt, dass die Geräte in Niederland nicht mehr eingesetzt werden. Da wurde erwähnt, dass die Republik Irland die Geräte angeschafft hat, aber nie verwendet hat. Und da wurde über Probleme mit Wahlcomputern in den USA berichtet. Und da war also schon klar, dass sie das Thema wirklich ernst nehmen. Das sieht man auch schon aus dem Umstand, dass sie überhaupt eine mündliche Verhandlung gegeben hat. Damit hatten wir eigentlich nicht gerechnet. Das Verfassungsgericht entscheidet nicht regelmäßig mit mündlicher Verhandlung, sondern entscheidet regelmäßig auf dem Schriftweg. Die mündliche Verhandlung ist die große Ausnahme. Das machen die bei Themen, wo es entweder noch tatsächlich was aufzuklären gibt, oder wo, ich nehme mal an, eine gewisse Öffentlichkeitswirkung hergestellt werden soll. Wir hatten nicht damit gerechnet, dass es eine mündliche Verhandlung gibt. Von den Stückzahlen her muss man sich vorstellen, das Gericht hat jedes Jahr 6.000 Verfahrenseingänge. Und davon werden 100 tatsächlich entschieden. Und davon kommen 10 in die mündliche Verhandlung.
10 Stück?
10 Stück.
Okay, das ist schon eine gewisse Wichtigkeit.
Das passiert nur bei Themen...
Wie kurzfristig wurde sowas anberaunt? Vier Wochen. Vier Wochen. Das heißt, eigentlich hatten sie ja vier Wochen Zeit, sich sozusagen darauf vorzubereiten. Und müssten sie dann sozusagen auch schon selber sehen, dass das wichtig ist. Du meinst ja, sie wären jetzt irgendwie überrascht gewesen. Sie waren dann überrascht, wie diese mündliche Verhandlung gelaufen ist oder dass es überhaupt einen gab?
Ich glaube, die sind überrascht davon gewesen, wie die Verhandlung gelaufen ist. Und die haben sozusagen ritualhaft die Argumente vorgetragen, die auch schon vorher nicht richtiger waren. Mit denen vorher immer der Bundestag und auch Journalisten abgefertigt wurden. Zum Beispiel das mit dem Argument, dass die Geräte sicher aufbewahrt werden und dass die jetzt versiegelt sind und deswegen nicht mehr manipuliert werden können. Und solche Geschichten. Oder dass man ja am Ergebnis sehen könnte, ob das richtig sei. Denn wenn man manipuliert würde, dann müsste man ja auch Stimmen verschieben und dann müsste man ja auch hinterher sehen, dass was anderes rauskommt. Oder was anderes als in den Nachbargemeinden, oder wie auch immer, oder als man erwartet. Und sonst hätte das Manipulieren ja keinen Sinn. Das hat der hessische Wahlleiter vorgetragen. Das hatte er vorher auch schon in der Presse mehrfach vorgetragen. Das wurde dann von den Journalisten anscheinend genutzt. Aber der Berichterstatter, der da die Fragen gestellt hatte, der wurde da richtig böse und fragte...
Welcher Berichterstatter jetzt? Während dieser vermutlichigen Verhandlung?
Genau, der Berichterstatter vom Gericht. Also im Gericht gibt es einen Richter, der das Verfahren sozusagen fachlich leitet. Und das ist der Berichterstatter, denn der berichtet seinen Kollegen.
Nicht jeder ist so voll involviert. Sie kommen sozusagen zusammen, aber es gibt einen, der sich hauptamtlich mit diesem Fall beschäftigt.
Genau, und das ist der Berichterstatter. Also hat jetzt nichts mit Journalismus zu tun, sondern...
Muss man auch mal klarstellen.
Genau.
Okay, und der hat dann irgendwie was gemacht?
Und der hat...
Also dieser Wahlleiter war auch da?
Ja, dieser hessische Wahlleiter war auch da. Und Herr Hannapel, und der hatte... Hatte dann also vorgetragen, dass eigentlich... Also erstens das Übliche, dass die Geräte tatsächlich sicher aufbewahrt werden in der Regel. Und dass deswegen durch diese organisatorischen Maßnahmen eine Manipulation nicht möglich sei. Und dann aber auch, dass ja eine Manipulation nicht aussichtsreich sei, weil wenn man manipulieren würde, müsste man ja auch Stimme verschieben. Und dann würde das Wahlergebnis unglaubwürdig.
Hatte auch erklärt, woran man das dann erkennt.
Und damit ist er halt, mit diesem Argument ist er halt in der Presse oft wenigstens so erfolgreich gewesen, dass das dann auch gedruckt wurde. Aber der Richter wurde dann richtig böse und sagte, wie wollen sie denn da sehen, ob das Ergebnis richtig ist oder nicht. Da muss doch nur eine Partei wie die Linke dazukommen. Da haben sie doch schon ein völlig anderes Ergebnis als beim letzten Mal. Wie wollen sie denn da sehen, dass das...
Und was meinte er dann dazu?
Ja, und so sind die da mehrfach überfahren worden. Die standen da einfach sprachlos rum? Die standen sprachlos rum und waren offensichtlich untereinander nicht gut abgesprochen, nicht gut koordiniert. Und wer auch nicht gut ausgesehen hat, war der Professor Richter von der Physikalischen Bundesanstalt, der sich also dann von den Gutachtern, von den technischen Gutachtern, die da waren, sagen lassen musste, dass die Geräte sehr wohl manipulierbar sind und dass man auch nicht erkennen kann, ob eine Manipulation stattgefunden hat.
Welchen technischen Gutachtern? Also zu wem gehören die?
Das war ein Gutachter, der das Gericht bestellt hat.
Das heißt also das Verfassungsgericht hat eigene technische Gutachten nochmal in Auftrag gegeben, um auch diese Stellungnahmen von der PTB unter anderem überprüfen zu können?
Für die mündliche Verhandlung hatten die zwei Leute eingeladen, die eigentlich von der e-Voting-Seite her kommen, nämlich einmal die Frau Vollkammer, die auch das Schutzprofil für den Wahlstift in Hamburg geschrieben hat, und zum anderen den Herrn Müller-Quade aus Karlsruhe, der das Bingo-Voting erfunden hat. Das ist so ein cryptografisches System, mit dem man angeblich nachprüfen können soll, ob die eigene Stimme richtig gezählt worden ist. Und die zwei waren als Gutachter da vom Gericht bestellt, um sich eben zu technischen Fragen zu äußern. Und die wurden dann eben auch gefragt zur Sicherheit der Geräte. Und das wurde dann also doch sehr, sehr schnell klar, dass die der Meinung sind, dass diese NEDAP-Geräte eben nicht sehr sicher sind. Und dass man auch Manipulationen nicht erkennen kann. Weder Hardware noch Software mit Manipulationen. Und dass man sehr hohen Aufwand treiben muss, um so etwas tatsächlich zu entdecken. Und nachdem diese Stellungnahmen abgegeben worden sind von den Gutachten, hatte man den Eindruck, dass das Innenministerium, die PTB bzw. Professor Richter fallen ließ wie eine heiße Kartoffel. Die hatten einfach keine geschlossene Front, sondern das war alles sehr stark im Fluss in dieser Verhandlung.
Was heißt, sie haben ihn fallen gelassen?
Da wurde dann gesagt, ja, im Ausblick. Wir denken ja sowieso schon nach, sagt das BMI, wie das jetzt weitergehen soll. Wir bereiten auch schon eine neue Wahlgeräteordnung vor. Und wir überlegen auch, ob wir das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik involvieren. Wurde also schon so abgerückt von der PTB. Das war alles so ein bisschen ins Blaue gesprochen, hatte man den Eindruck. Und da wurde eben auch wieder nachgehakt von den Richtern. Ach, sagen Sie doch mal, was planen Sie denn da so mit der Bundeswahlgeräteordnung? Wie weit sind Sie denn da schon gedienen? Und da musste der vom BMI dann aber sagen, wir sind da noch nicht im Stadium des Referentenentwurfes.
Mit anderen Worten, politische Äußerung ohne viel Saft dahinter. Das heißt, es gab genau diese eine öffentliche Anhörung?
Es gab genau diese eine öffentliche Anhörung. Und ja, das war wirklich eine irre Erfahrung. Also zum einen, weil man einfach als Ortonormalverbraucher tatsächlich sowas erreichen kann. Und dann tatsächlich auch Gehör findet. Jedenfalls, wenn man mit einem Anliegen kommt, dass die Richter offensichtlich interessiert, und wo man seine Argumente gut vorträgt. Aber auch zum anderen war das eine gute Erfahrung, dass die Gegenseite, das Innenministerium oder auch die PTW, mit den ganzen halbgaren Argumenten, die die vorher drei Jahre lang vorgetragen hatten, und wo man sozusagen dem immer ausgeliefert war, mit diesen halbgaren Argumenten, dass sie da mit diesen Argumenten vor eine Wand liefen. Und dass da nachgebohrt wurde und dass da nachgefragt wurde. Und dass auf einem sehr hohen intellektuellen Niveau da Grenzen gezogen wurden. Die Richter waren super vorbereitet. Die wussten genau, wovon sie reden. Die hatten sich tatsächlich so einen Wahlcomputer kommen lassen und da aufbauen lassen im Gericht. Und der Vorsitzende vom Senat sagte dann auch, ich kann Ihnen mitteilen, wir konnten alle damit wählen.
Wir waren in der Lage, das Gerät zu bedienen.
Und wir waren aber überrascht, was hinterher als Wahlergebnis rauskam. Wirklich?
Humor haben sie auf jeden Fall auch.
Humor haben sie auch. Es war einfach eine gute Erfahrung.
Zeigt noch mal was zur Rolle des Klubs in dem Zusammenhang. Ihr seid alleine gestartet, da gab es diese Verbindung zum CCC noch nicht. Später ist man dann sozusagen zueinander gekommen. Welche Rolle hat der Klub in dieser Anhörung und vielleicht auch in dem Verlauf bis dahin gespielt? Wie bewertest du das? Du bist ja kein CCC-Mitglied. Du bist ja nicht Teil dieser Bewegung gewesen. Du hast ja nur ein Anliegen vertreten, was eben auch im Klub einen sehr hohen inhaltlichen Stellenwert hatte.
Der Klub war letztendlich die erste Gruppe von Menschen, von denen ich sehr positives Feedback bekommen habe zu dem Thema. Das ging schon los, als ich noch nicht mal den Wahleinspruch abgegeben hatte, sondern einfach nur mich kritisch dazu geäußert hatte über Heise. Nachdem ich diese Mitteilung vom BMI bekommen hatte, dass mich das alles nichts angeht mit den Prüfunterlagen, wurde ich angesprochen vom Club, ob ich nicht mal einen Vortrag beim Kongress zu dem Thema halten wollte. So ist man sich dann näher gekommen. Es gibt ja im Club doch einige Leute, die sich sehr intensiv mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt haben. Dazu gehört nicht nur der Hack zusammen mit Rob und den Leuten aus den Niederlanden, sondern dazu gehören auch eine ganze Reihe von Wahlbeobachtungen, die der CCC gemacht hat und bei denen ja auch eine Menge rausgekommen ist. Ich hatte an diese Wahlbeobachtungen gar nicht so geglaubt. Ich war eigentlich davon überzeugt, dass man da eigentlich nur sehen kann, dass man nichts sehen kann. Aber da ist doch über die Einsatzrealität einiges zu Tage gekommen, zum Beispiel, dass die Geräte tatsächlich nicht sicher gelagert werden, wie das immer behauptet wurde von der Physikalischen Bundesanstalt oder vom Innenministerium. Das ist letztendlich auch nicht zu erwarten gewesen, dass die Geräte sicher gelagert werden, weil das nämlich auch gar nicht so vorgeschrieben ist. Sondern da hätte man sozusagen...
Das ist nur eine Behauptung.
Das ist nur eine Behauptung immer gewesen, aber das Wahlrecht schreibt sowas nicht vor. Das heißt, das war immer schon so eine nachgeschobene Argumentation. Das war sogar 2005 noch so. 2006 hat der Hersteller noch auf einer Anwendertagung festgestellt, dass die Geräte überhaupt nicht sicher gelagert sein müssten, weil die nämlich ja auch nicht zu manipulieren sind.
Sie sind ja sicher, deswegen müsste man sie nicht sicher lagern. Und dann fragt man die anderen, warum sind sie denn sicher? Sie sind vor allem deshalb sicher, weil sie ja sicher gelagert sind.
Als der Hack da draußen war, da wurden die Geräte dann plötzlich doch sicher gelagert. Und auch schon immer. Das war aber eben nicht geregelt. Das heißt, da hätten die Gemeinden selber drauf kommen müssen. Und zum Beispiel die Wahlleiter haben dann auch in Podiumsdiskussionen, die man sowohl gelegentlich erlebt hat, dann auch noch erzählt, noch 2007 erzählt, dass die Geräte nicht sicher gelagert werden müssen, weil das einfach bei denen noch nicht angekommen war. Und das kann man dann eben im Feldversuch auch erleben. Beziehungsweise in der Wahlbeobachtung, dass die Geräte eben irgendwo gelagert werden. Und vielleicht auch teilweise hinter verschlossenen Türen, aber eben teilweise auch nicht hinter verschlossenen Türen, sondern bei Wahlvorständen an der Nacht vor der Wahl. Oder ja, teilweise sind die Geräte ja auch verliehen worden an private Dritte, also zum Beispiel für Aktionärsversammlungen oder Betriebsratswahlen und solche Geschichten. Und da gibt man natürlich die Kontrolle über die Geräte schon aus der Hand. Und also diese sichere Aufbewahrungsrealität, das hat die Wahlbeobachtung zum Beispiel aufgedeckt, aber auch Probleme, die die Wahlhelfer mit den Geräten haben, einfach Bedienprobleme, weil da Leute, die eben keinen technischen Hintergrund haben und die auch keine Erfahrung haben mit den Geräten, weil die ja das nur alle vier Jahre mal machen, oder alle so und so viele Jahre.
So soll die Wahlhelfer vielleicht nur ein einziges Mal in ihrem Leben und dann nie wieder?
Genau, weil die Geräte ja auch nicht leichter zu bedienen sind, jedenfalls aus der Wahlhelferperspektive, als man einen Videorecorder programmieren kann. Damit haben ja auch genügend Leute schon Probleme, obwohl man das in der Regel öfters macht. Das heißt, es gab immer wieder Berichte davon, dass Wahlhelfer einfach Schwierigkeiten hatten mit der Bedienung der Geräte und dass es zur Verzögerung bei den Betriebnahmen gekommen ist. Und es gab auch Berichte über Warteschlangen. Das heißt darüber, dass eben nicht, wie es im Bundeswahlgesetz steht, die Geräte Erleichterungen bei der Stimmabgabe schaffen, sondern dass die Geräte Wartezeiten schaffen. Weil man eben nicht, wie in einem normalen Wahllokal, da zwei, drei Wahlkabinen stehen haben kann. Weil eine Wahlkabine nichts kostet. Man bräuchte drei Computer, um keine Schlange zu haben. Aber man kann nur einen bezahlen, wenn man die Kosten und Vorteile haben will. Und wenn man dann das noch kombiniert mit einem komischen Wahlverfahren, wo die Leute viel Zeit brauchen, weil sie 70 Stimmen verteilen müssen. Oder wo sie viel Zeit brauchen, weil die 600 Wahlvorschläge, die es da gibt in der Stadt, sich nicht alle in vernünftiger Schiftgröße auf diesem Tableau abbilden. Solche Sachen lassen sich dann eben beobachten, wenn man tatsächlich da ist. Das hat viel gebracht und da haben wir viel gelernt über die tatsächliche Einsatzwirklichkeit, die eben nicht so rosig ist, wie das immer gefeiert wurde.
Was hat der Club in der Anhörung konkret beigetragen?
In der Anhörung war der Club nicht geladen. Da waren zwar viele Leute da vom Club, um sozusagen den Rücken zu stärken, aber der Club hatte dann sozusagen mit seinem Gutachten da schon für ausreichend Wirbel gesorgt in dem Verfahren.
Das heißt, bei dieser Anhörung wurde im Prinzip wirklich eigentlich mehr das Statement der Gegenseite eingeholt?
Ja, tatsächlich war es so, dass in der Anhörung ganz überwiegend die Gegenseite geredet hat. Das heißt, die mussten sich der kritischen Fragen gefallen lassen. Es lief also meistens so ab, dass zum jeweiligen nächsten Themenbereich einer von unseren Anwälten ein Statement abgegeben hat, ein Eingangsstatement. Und dann gab es ein Eingangsstatement von der Gegenseite, entweder vom Bundestag oder vom Innenministerium oder von der PTB. Und dann stellten die Richter Fragen und stellten kritische Fragen. Und ließen sich da nicht an der Nase herumführen. Und das war wirklich eine gute Erfahrung. Und es war auch alles sehr strukturiert und sehr logisch, was die da gemacht haben, die Richter. Und ich kann nur jedem nahelegen, sich mal so eine Verhandlung anzugucken, auch wenn es ein Thema ist, das einen vielleicht gar nicht so sehr interessiert oder einen nicht selber betrifft, weil das einfach eine gute rechtsstaatliche Erfahrung ist, so was mal mitzuerleben.
So, und dann war die Anhörung irgendwann zu Ende und die Richter haben sich sozusagen zur Entscheidung zurückgezogen. Das dauert aber eine Weile.
Und das hat in dem Fall vier Monate gedauert.
Gibt es da so eine zeitliche Grenze bis wann die dann auch das Urteil gesprochen haben müssen?
Also im Bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetz steht, dass sie innerhalb von drei Monaten nach der möglichen Verhandlung entscheiden sollen. Und das haben sie bei uns nicht ganz eingehalten. Aber es gibt auch da letztendlich niemanden, der sie da maßregelt. Und mir war es schnell genug.
Okay. Aber es gab schon so ein bisschen Handlungsbedarf, weil es ja schon klar war, dass dieses Urteil für die jetzt 2009 anstehenden Bundestagswahlen ja auch maßgebliche Auswirkungen haben könnte.
Ja, die erste unmittelbare Auswirkung war eigentlich, dass bei der Hessenwahl im Januar, bei der vorgezogenen hessischen Landtagswahl, die Geräte in Hessen nicht zugelassen worden sind vom Landeswahlleiter. Weil da einfach zu befürchten war aus Sicht des Landeswahlleiters, dass das Urteil des Gerichtes zeitlich sehr nahe liegen würde bei der Wahl. Sodass man dann letztendlich entweder eine Woche vor der Wahl die Geräte aus der Hand geschlagen bekommt. Oder eine Woche nach der Wahl, was vielleicht noch der schlimmere Fall gewesen wäre, mitgeteilt bekommt, dass das alles leider nicht gültig war.
Jetzt bitte nochmal. Und Wahlen haben sie ja nun wirklich genug gehabt in Hessen in dieser Zeit. Aber das zeugt sich schon von einer gewissen Verunsicherung.
Also das zeugte jedenfalls von der Einsicht auf der Seite der Wahlgeräte-Befürworter, dass die Verhandlung wohl nicht so gut gelaufen ist.
Ja, machen wir nochmal einen zeitlichen Sprung, weil zwischendurch ist ja da nicht so sehr viel passiert. Jetzt kam es zur Urteilsverkündung und das ist ja auch schon bekannt. Wenn ich das richtig sehe, wurde eigentlich eurem Anliegen, wie nennt man es, der Beschwerde, weitgehend zugestimmt. Kann man das so sagen? Wie war das? Also ihr wart wieder in diesem gleichen Saal?
Ja, wir waren wieder im gleichen Saal und saßen wieder auf den gleichen Stühlen. Und dann kam das Gericht rein und las wieder vor, wer anwesend ist. Und dann ging es gleich ins Eingemachte.
Im Namen des Volkes?
Im Namen des Volkes ergeht folgendes Urteil. Der Einsatz der Wahlgeräte zur Bundestagswahl 2005 war verfassungswidrig. Die Bundeswahlgeräteverordnung ist verfassungswidrig. Im Übrigen wird die Wahlprüfungsbeschwerde zurückgewiesen.
Mit anderen Worten?
Das heißt, mit anderen Worten, wir haben in der Sache Recht. Aber dieser formale Ansatz, den wir machen mussten, dass wir die Wahl angreifen, das Wahlergebnis von der Bundestagswahl 2005, damit waren wir nicht erfolgreich. Und da wären wir allerdings, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen erschrocken gewesen, wenn wir damit erfolgreich gewesen wären.
Das heißt, ihr habt im Prinzip auch schon damit gerechnet, dass es jetzt keine nachträglichen Auswirkungen hat auf die Wahl. Aber darum ging es ja letztlich auch nicht wirklich.
Darum ging es nicht.
Ja, also was besagt denn das Urteil? Wie hat denn das Gericht jetzt eigentlich argumentiert? Und welcher Linie sind Sie da gefolgt?
Das Gericht sagt, dass alle wesentlichen Schritte der Wahl öffentliche Überprüfbarkeit unterliegen. Das heißt, dass jedermann...
Unterliegen müssen.
Und Sie sagen, dass, wenn elektronische Wahlgeräte eingesetzt werden, und das wollen Sie nicht völlig ausschließen, dann müssen die wesentlichen Schritte der Wahlhandlung und der Ergebnisermittlung vom Bürger zuverlässig und ohne besondere Sachkenntnisse überprüft werden können. So steht das in den beiden Leitsätzen.
Das heißt, Leitsätze, die wirklich jetzt Teil des Urteils sind?
Die sind dem Urteil vorangestellt. Und daraus wird dann alles entwickelt. Was in dem Urteil steht.
Also diese Leitsätze sagen sozusagen aus, in welchem Geist dieses Urteil ergangen ist.
Genau.
Also unsere grundsätzliche Prämisse ist, dass das so und so zu sein hat. Und daraus folgern wir.
Genau. Und für mich das Entscheidende ist, dass die Wahl selber und auch die Ermittlung des Ergebnisses ohne besondere Sachkenntnisse vom Bürger überprüft werden muss. Da steckt einiges drin. Da steckt nämlich drin, dass es eben vom Bürger überprüft werden können muss und nicht etwa von Behörde XY. Und da steckt drin, dass es ohne besondere Sachkenntnisse überprüft werden muss. Das heißt, nicht etwa von irgendwelchen Spezialisten, die vor der Wahl zur PTW gehen und sich die Geräte angucken, auch wenn sie Bürger sind, sondern dass auch, ja, Alicia Müller in der Lage sein muss, zu verstehen, was da passiert. Und das ist sehr weitgehend, wie ich meine. Und das hat doch erhebliche Auswirkungen darauf, wie man in Zukunft Wahlgeräte einsetzen kann oder nicht. Denn die ganze Diskussion, die wir auch geführt haben, darüber, wie öffentlich eigentlich das Zulassungsverfahren sein muss, ob man da Einsicht haben muss in die technischen Unterlagen und in den Quellcode und ob man in der Lage sein muss, die Geräte vielleicht auch selber zu überprüfen, die hat sich damit praktisch völlig erledigt. Das heißt, dass das Verfahren rund um die Wahlgeräte so organisiert sein muss, dass es darauf nicht mehr ankommt. Das heißt, man erkennt einfach an, dass so ein Wahlgerät eine Blackbox ist. Und das Wahlverfahren muss eben so organisiert sein, dass wenn ich so eine Blackbox einsetze, dass es überhaupt keine Rolle spielen darf, was in dieser Kiste passiert. Also zum Beispiel ein Verfahren, das man sich da vorstellen könnte, ist ein Verfahren, wo tatsächlich, der einfachste Fall ist vielleicht ein Scannerverfahren, bei dem ich ganz normal mal ein Kreuz auf dem Papier mache und wo die hinterher gescannt werden, diese Zettel und elektronisch ausgewertet.
Also sozusagen, dass man jetzt auch den Zeitpunkt, also es geht ja um die Automatisierung der Wahl, nicht? Immer dieses, wir hätten es gerne schneller, höher, weiter und so weiter, damit das irgendwie alles ganz toll ist. Und bisher war das Prinzip, dass die eigentliche Stimmabgabe schon in den Computer abgespeichert wird und dann zählt das einfach aus. Das geht nun im Prinzip überhaupt nicht mehr. Also das lese ich jetzt auch so ein bisschen daraus. Und du meinst, ein möglicher Ansatz wäre, dass man jetzt den Zettel dann scannen, dass man sozusagen nicht Leute, das irgendwie...
Aber da kannst du dir dann auch nicht zugucken, wenn du einen Scanner hast, der das schnell macht. Sondern das Verfahren muss dann so aussehen, dass auch Lisa Müller, die von Scannern keine Ahnung hat, überprüfen kann, dass das richtig gezählt wird. Und das heißt, es reicht eben nicht, das automatisch zu zählen, sondern ich muss auch noch auf eine Art und Weise das Überprüfen des Ergebnisses, wo Lisa Müller mitmacht, also zugucken kann. Das heißt, man kommt im Prinzip an der Handauszählung nicht vorbei, wenn sich nicht jemand etwas wurchtbar cleveres ausdenkt. Und es darf einfach keine Rolle spielen, wie das elektronische Gerät, das die Stimmen auszählt oder erfasst, funktioniert. Das darf nicht eine Rolle spielen bei der Überprüfbarkeit des Ergebnisses. Und darf auch keine Rolle spielen bei der Überprüfbarkeit durch den Bürger, der dabei zuguckt. Und das ist einfach sehr weitgehend. Und dann kommt es auch tatsächlich nicht mehr darauf an, ob da auf diesem Gerät Quellcode läuft, der Open Source ist oder Close Source, oder wie das Gerät im Einzelnen konstruiert ist. Das ist einfach viel weitgehender, hätte es eigentlich nicht sein können. Und die Richter sagen, im Prinzip schließen wir Internetwahlen und elektronische Wahlen nicht aus, aber ihr müsst dafür sorgen, dass das ebenso transparent ist wie eine Wahl mit Papier und Bleistift. Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das tatsächlich geht, ohne dass man den eigentlichen Nutzen der Wahlgeräte zerstört, nämlich die Einsparung beim Auszählen. Denn ohne das Auszählen wird es einfach nicht gehen, die Überprüfbarkeit zu erhalten.
Also eigentlich ein voller Erfolg.
Eigentlich ein voller Erfolg.
Also siehst du ja jetzt auch, in dieser Aussage, von den üblichen Verdächtigen gab es natürlich dann auch gleich wieder die zu erwartenden Statements. Die Lieblingsformulierung, die ich immer so nach jedem Verfassungsgerichtsurteil der letzten zwei Jahre dann immer so lese, ist so, wir danken dem Gericht für die Klarstellung. Ja, jetzt herrscht halt endlich Klarheit darüber. Und es wurde ja auch mal Zeit, dass das sozusagen mal wieder alles eingenordert wird. Jetzt können wir wieder so weitermachen wie bisher. Solche Reaktionen gab es ja auch. Was weiß ich, Wahlleiter, die befragt wurden, kamen damit hoch. Na ja, jetzt müsste man halt mal gucken, wie man die Geräte modifizieren kann, damit sie dann eben in Zukunft auch weiter betrieben werden können. Da müssen wir mal schauen, ob wir da vielleicht mal einen Drucker einbauen oder so. Hat das irgendeinen, ich meine, ist da noch ein Funken Realität in solchen Reaktionen? Oder denkst du, damit ist es eigentlich vorbei?
Also man kann da sicherlich einen Drucker dran bauen. Und man kann die Stimmen auch ausdrucken und dann in eine Urne schmeißen und am Ende des Tages auszählen. Aber dann zählt man eben auch am Ende des Tages aus. Und dann kann man es auch gleich lassen mit den Wahlcomputern.
Weil da hat man im Prinzip nur den Bleistift durch einen Computer ersetzt.
Und dann hat man den Bleistift durch einen Computer ersetzt, genau, so ist das.
Und anstatt dass man irgendwie zehn Bleistifte anschafft, müsste man zehn Computer anschaffen, hätte aber eigentlich kein weiterer Nutzen davon.
Ja, es wirkt halt moderner, ne?
Ja, Modernität hat ihren Preis, sag ich dazu noch. Ja, ich meine, worauf ich hinausfälle, ist eigentlich, jetzt haben wir dieses Urteil, und es ist ja eigentlich fast gar nicht zu fassen. Also wenn du sagst, ja, jetzt ist ja eigentlich vorbei, so ist die Frage, was ist jetzt vorbei? Weil es gibt natürlich jetzt einige Neumarkluge, die natürlich dann auch gleich wieder mit anderen System-Ideen hervorkommen, so insbesondere dieser Aspekt der Internetwahl, so nach dem Motto, naja, man müsste ja, es kann ja nicht sein, dass ich meine Flugreise im Internet buchen kann, mit irgendwie Doppelklick zwischen zwei und fünf Uhr so nachts, aber wählen nicht. Ich meine, solche Reaktionen wirst du kennen. Es gibt so ein Argument dazu.
Da muss man sich einfach nochmal das Problem angucken, dass man da eigentlich zu lösen versucht bei einer Wahl. Und der Unterschied zwischen anderen IT-Problemen oder Problemen, mit denen man in der Informationstechnik zu tun hat, ist, dass man eben anders als beim Geldautomaten nicht weiß, was man für eine Eingabe hat. Und man kann nicht eine geheime Eingabe in einen unbekannten Prozess stecken und erwarten, dass hinten was rauskommt, was man überprüfen kann. Das gilt sowohl für den Wähler mit seiner eigenen Stimme, als auch für Dritte, die sich das Ganze angucken wollen. Also wenn man zum Beispiel eine Bank ist und sich ein neues Buchhaltungssystem anschafft, dann muss man davon nicht den Code haben, um zu wissen, ob das funktioniert oder nicht.
Weil man immer einen Beleg hat?
Weil man protokolliert, was man vorne reinsteckt und protokolliert, was hinten rauskommt. Und da kann man einfach nachrechnen. Da muss man den Prozess nicht kennen und die Software nicht kennen. Es ist einfach überprüfbar, weil Eingabe und Ausgabe bekannt ist.
Aber das geht ja bei einer Wahl nicht, weil sie geheim sein muss.
Genau, das geht bei einer Wahl nicht, weil sie geheim sein muss. Und das ist das eigentliche Problem. Und ich sehe auch nicht, wie man das Problem vernünftig lösen kann, wenn man nicht sozusagen eine Kopie von der Eingabe nimmt und die dann auch noch auf eine andere Art und Weise verarbeitet. Zum Beispiel durch händisches Auszählen. Das funktioniert ja beim händischen Auszählen deswegen, weil ich da einen Prozess habe, den ich sehen und beobachten kann. Und da habe ich dann zwar auch eine geheime Eingabe, bzw. durch das Mischen der Stimmen wird die einzelne Stimme geheim, aber der Prozess selber ist beobachtbar, und deswegen ist auch das Ergebnis überprüfbar. Und das ist eben genau der Unterschied zum Wahlcomputer. Und ich kann einen Wahlcomputer dann einsetzen, wenn ich eben dieses zweifache Verarbeiten mache, einmal durch den Computer und dann die Kopie der Stimme oder das Original der Stimme auch noch händisch auszähle. Dann habe ich hinterher was, was ich überprüfen kann. Dann kann ich die Ergebnisse vergleichen. Und dann stimmt es oder stimmt es nicht. Aber wenn ich auf dieses händische Auszählen verzichte, dann kann ich das Problem nicht lösen. Also eine geheime Eingabe und ein geheimer Prozess oder ein nicht beobachtbarer Prozess ist niemals überprüfbar. Und daran, denke ich, wird man sich in Kombination mit dem Urteil auch die Zähne ausbeißen.
Es gibt ja so ein paar Leute, die auch schon gleich ihre tollen Ideen sozusagen zur Diskussion gestellt haben. Du hast ja vorhin schon dieses Bingo-Voting erwähnt. Das wird, glaube ich, von den Unterstützern auch mal schnell wieder als mögliche Alternative geboten. Was steckt da dahinter?
Also es gibt eine ganze Reihe kryptographische Verfahren, oder ich würde mal eher sagen Gedankenexperimente, mit Testimplementierungen gegebenenfalls auch, gelegentlich auch, wo Kryptografen sagen, wir haben ja ein Verfahren, wo wir diese Überprüfbarkeit lösen, indem wir auf irgendeine verschlüsselte Form dem Wähler eine Quittung in die Hand geben, mit der er zwar nicht nachweisen kann, was er gewählt hat, mit der er aber überprüfen kann, ob seine Stimme irgendwo hinten bei den gezählten Stimmen dabei ist.
Aber er kann nicht überprüfen, ob auch das, was er gewählt wurde, dabei ist oder wie. Ich meine, dass meine Stimme gezählt wurde, ist in dem Moment ja hinfällig, wo ich nicht weiß, ob sie überhaupt richtig erfasst wurde.
Also bei Bingo-Voting, wo wir schon das Beispiel haben, also Bingo-Voting unterscheidet sich von anderen kryptischen Verfahren eigentlich vor allem durch zwei Sachen. Das eine ist, es ist ein Verfahren, das hier aus Deutschland kommt, wenn die meisten anderen kryptographischen Verfahren, die ich kenne, aus den USA kommen. Und zum anderen hat es den IT-Sicherheitspreis bekommen letztes Jahr. Und das hat für einigen Medienrummel und einige Aufmerksamkeit gesorgt, für dieses Bingo-Voting. Das Bingo-Voting funktioniert so, dass man für jeden Wähler und jede Wahl, die der Wähler treffen kann, vorher eine Zufallszahl festlegt. Und diese Zufallszahlen bekommen sozusagen Stempel, also sowas wie ein Hech gezogen, damit man die nicht mehr verändern kann. Und dann kriegt der Wähler, wenn der Wähler seine Auswahl trifft, dann wird für jede Auswahl, die er getroffen hat, diese vorher bestimmte Zufallszahl ausgetauscht gegen eine frische gezogene Zufallszahl. Und diese frische Zufallszahl soll aus einem Bingo-Käfig kommen, also aus einem Lottozahlengerät, also da kommt der Name her. Aber natürlich kommt die dann tatsächlich nicht aus einem Bingo-Gerät, sondern aus irgendeinem elektronischen Gerät, das irgendwelche Zufallszahlen erzeugt, auf welche Art und Weise auch immer. Und der Wähler kriegt dann eine Quittung, auf dem lauter Zufallszahlen draufstehen. Nämlich die ursprünglichen Zufallszahlen, die vor der Wahl vorbereitet worden sind von der Auswahl, die er nicht getroffen hat. Und die neue Zufallszahl, die ersetzt die alte Zufallszahl von seinem Wahlverschlag, den er gewählt hat. Man kann dann also überprüfen, dass die frische Zufallszahl, die vor seinen Augen ermittelt wurde, dass die dasteht, bei dem, was er gewählt hat.
Das heißt, man muss sich dann eine Zahl merken?
Man kriegt eine Quittung, die kann man mitnehmen.
Zum Zeitpunkt der Wahl?
Zum Zeitpunkt der Wahl. Zum Zeitpunkt der Wahl muss man dann vergleichen, dass der Zufallszahlengenerator die gleiche Zahl anzeigt, wie die Zahl, die daneben seiner Auswahl steht.
Am Gerät?
Am Gerät. Da nimmt man diese Quittung mit.
Das ist dann aber eine lange Zahl?
Das ist eine lange Zahl, Zehnziffern oder sowas. Mit der Quittung gehst du nach Hause. Dann kannst du dann nach der Wahl auf deinem Balletinboard nachschauen, ob deine Quittung dabei ist und ob die richtigen Zahlen draufstehen. Und dann gibt es mathematische Beweise, mit denen man beweisen kann, dass tatsächlich auf jeder Quittung, die da drin ist, auf diesem Balletinboard, dass da nicht irgendwie, also dass da jede Partei genau oder jeder Wahlvorschlag genau eine Zufallszahl hat und dass das noch die alten Zufallszahlen sind von vorher und all solche Geschichten. Und zu dem Verfahren gibt es verschiedene Sachen zu sagen. Zum einen hängt die Wirksamkeit des Verfahrens ganz erheblich davon ab, ob die Zufallszahlen, die gezogen werden, tatsächlich Zufallszahlen sind. Das heißt, wenn man die Zahlen kontrolliert, kann man auch Stimmen verschieben. Das heißt, das ist eigentlich nur eine Transformation des Problems. Bei einem NEDAP-Wahlcomputer muss ich vertrauen, dass er richtig zählt. Und bei einem Bingo-Voting-System muss ich vertrauen, dass es richtig Zufallszahlen zählt, also Zufallszahlen erzeugt.
Das sieht man aber den Zahlen ja nicht unbedingt an, wie zufällig sie jetzt eigentlich wirklich sind.
Es gibt überhaupt keine Möglichkeit zu beweisen, dass Zufallszahlen Zufallszahlen sind. Man kann höchstens nachweisen, dass Zufallszahlen keine Zufallszahlen sein können. Wenn immer bestimmte Wiederholungen sich endlos wiederholen, dann kann man sagen, das sind keine Zufallszahlen. Aber man kann nicht sagen, hier diese Zahlen, das sind Zufallszahlen. Es gibt keinen positiven Beweis.
Ich denke auch, dieses Urteil, du hast ja betont, dass das Urteil auch gesagt hat, dass es besonders einfach und für jedermann nachvollziehbar sein muss. Ich denke, bei älteren Leuten wird schon das Vergleichen von zwei langen Zahlen zu einem Problem führen.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, selbst wenn man die eigentliche Prüfhandlung ausführen kann, heißt das ja nicht, dass man versteht, was man da eigentlich prüft. Und da kannst du schon mal ein paar ausgewachsene Mathematiker im Nachmittag mit beschäftigen, zu verstehen, was da eigentlich passiert.
Und das widerspricht sozusagen auch dem Leitsetzen des Urteils?
Ich würde sagen, das widerspricht dem Leitsetzen des Urteils ganz erheblich. Also aus verschiedenen Gründen. Erstens, weil es eben wieder darauf angewiesen ist, dass die Zufallszahlen zufällig sind. Das lässt sich nicht beobachten, damit ist die ganze Sache eigentlich erledigt. Und zum anderen eben, weil das Verfahren selber so kompliziert ist, dass man es nicht verstehen kann als Laie. Und auch eigentlich als nicht Laie kann man es fast nicht verstehen. Und was aber letztendlich dem Verfahren dann sowieso den GAR ausmacht, ist die Benutzbarkeit. Man kann bei einer Bürgermeisterwahl mit, was weiß ich, zwei Kandidaten oder von mir aus auch bei einer Bundestagswahl mit zwei Stimmen und zehn verschiedenen Parteien und zehn Direktkandidaten, da kann man vielleicht noch nachgucken, ob die zwei Zufallszahlen, die man bekommt für die beiden Stimmen, die man hat, ob die tatsächlich mit dem übereinstimmen, was da auf Seite Quittung steht. Aber jetzt in einer Kommunalwahl hier in Hessen, wo du in Frankfurt 600 Kandidaten hast und 80 Stimmen vergibst, dann kannst du auf deinem Wahlzettel auf dem 1800 Zufallszahlen stehen, kannst du dann 80 mindestens 10-stellige Zahlen vergleichen, ob die Zahl auf dem Zufallszahlen-Generator übereinstimmt.
Ich denke, das Ergebnis wäre dann wahrscheinlich, dass sich mehrere tausend Leute nach der Wahl melden und sagen, das stimmt was nicht.
Also es meint davon abgesehen, dass das wahrscheinlich für jeden einzelnen Wähler doch eine Nachmittagsbeschäftigung wäre, da die Integrität seiner Stimme zu überprüfen. Die Benutzbarkeit dieser Verfahren kollabiert einfach in Situationen, wo eigentlich Wahltechnologie den meisten Nutzen bringt. Nämlich, wenn man mit vielen Stimmen kumuliert und panaschiert.
Was sind denn noch für Systeme so im Gespräch, die jetzt von irgendwelchen Befürwortern noch ins Feld geführt werden, die man jetzt auch noch machen könnte?
Es gibt ja den Wahlstift in Hamburg. Der ist ja auch noch nicht ganz tot. Also immerhin ist ja das Unternehmen, das den Wahlstift entwickelt hat, so lebendig oder auch noch so interessiert an dem Wahlstift, dass sie euch verklagt haben.
Also euch im Sinne von Chaos Computer Club?
Ich persönlich nicht.
Also verklagt haben auf Basis einer Behauptung, ob denn nun dieses Gräts tatsächlich gehackt wurde, nicht. In dem Fall handelt es sich sozusagen nicht um dasselbe, sondern um etwas, von dem behauptet wird, dass es das Gleiche ist. Aber das will ich jetzt auch nicht weiter kommentieren. Das kann ich, also weder kann ich das hier kommentieren, noch will ich das hier kommentieren.
Auf jeden Fall ist das sicherlich ein System, das sich jetzt auch wieder ins Gespräch bringen wird, kann ich mir vorstellen. Weil der Begriff Wahlstift auch ausdrücklich fällt im Urteil im Zusammenhang mit Systemen, die die Stimmen in einer angemessenen verkörperten Form auch erzeugen. Das heißt, du hast ja ein Blatt Papier beim Wahlstift, auf dem die Stimme tatsächlich physikalisch abgegeben wird. Und dieses Blatt wird auch dann in Ohne geschmissen. Das heißt, es erfolgt insofern den einen Teil der Anforderungen vom Gericht, dass das Ergebnis überprüfbar sein muss. Aber das Urteil würde dann auch verlangen, dass man diese physikalischen oder verkörperten Stimmen dann tatsächlich auch auszählt. Weil es sonst ja nicht überprüfbar ist. Sonst ist der Papierzettel ja nur eine Eingabeform für das digitale Leistung.
Also das leitest du schon aus dem Urteil, dass man das auch tun muss?
Ja, es muss für den Bürger zuverlässig und ohne Sachkenntnis überprüfbar sein, dass das Ergebnis stimmt.
Zum Zeitpunkt der Wahl oder im Nachhinein, theoretisch, wenn man es anzweifelt?
Wenn im Nachhinein nochmal nachgezählt wird, dann machen das ja nicht die Bürger oder sind auch keine Bürger dabei, sondern dann wird zum Beispiel auch bei einer Papierwahl jetzt in der Wahlbehörde nochmal nachgezählt zur Ergebnisüberprüfung. Aber das ist keine Kontrolle durch den Bürger, sondern eine Kontrolle durch die Wahlbehörde.
Das heißt, diese Aussage bezieht sich zwangsläufig auf die eigentliche Wahlhandlung?
Genau, die Wahlhandlung muss überprüfbar sein und das Ergebnis, die Ergebnisentwicklung muss überprüfbar sein. Und das ist sie nicht, wenn sie im Inneren eines Computers stattfindet, sondern nur, wenn man parallel das Ergebnis auch auf eine Art und Weise ermittelt.
Das heißt also auch, wenn man einen Wahlstift zum Einsatz bringt, müsste man eigentlich das Papier auszählen, wodurch eigentlich der Einsatz des Stiftes überflüssig ist, weil eigentlich nichts anderes tun würde, als eine zweite Auszählung zu bieten, die quasi eine Differenz, das wäre sozusagen als Korrektur für die Handauszählung.
Zum Beispiel, um zu wissen, wann man die Handauszählung nochmal wiederholen muss. Oder auch von mir aus bei so einem kumulierten Panaschirgen, wo das Auszähl dann möglicherweise über Tage geht, dass ich schon am Wahlabend ein Ergebnis habe, wenn ich meine, dass ich das unbedingt bräuchte.
Aber da gibt es ja auch viele Detailprobleme jetzt beim Wahlschiff. Man fällt mir nur ein, wenn die Leute keinen Wahlschiff verwenden in der Kabine. Man sieht das ja nicht. Sondern wenn sie irgendwie ihren eigenen Kugelschrauber mitbringen, dann hat zwangsläufig schon eine Stimmenabweichung. Ohne, dass man das nachvollziehen kann, dass das so war.
Genau, dann hat man das Problem, dass wenn man nicht durch das Wahlsystem tatsächlich auch die physikalisch verkörperte Stimme erzeugt, dass es da Divergänzen geben kann. Also wenn man sozusagen einen Computer hat, einen Drucker, dann ist das einfacher, dafür zu sorgen, dass auf dem Fahrzeug auch das drauf ist, was der Wähler gewählt hat.
Das heißt, du rechnest eigentlich auch nicht wirklich mit der Wiederkunft, das Wahlstift.
Der Wahlstift hat auch noch andere Probleme. Zum Beispiel kann man beim Wahlstift nicht ohne Weiteres die elektronischen Stimmen mit dem Papierstimm wieder zusammenführen, weil die ja keine Nummer haben oder so was. Das heißt, man kann nicht einfach einen Zettel rausnehmen und sagen, ist der denn richtig erfasst. Du musst praktisch alle Zettel auswerten, um die Richtigkeit beurteilen zu können. Dann kannst du keine Stichproben machen. Wenn du einen Drucker hast, der vielleicht sogar eine Nummer mit auf den Zettel schreibt, kannst du einfach sagen, ich nehme jetzt hier zehn Zettel und gucke, was in meinem Balletin-Board mit was für einer Stimme, über die da vermerkt sind. Und das ist beim Wahlstift ausgeschlossen.
Welche Möglichkeiten für eine Beteiligung elektronischer Geräte im Wahlprozess siehst du denn noch, also nach diesem Urteil in Deutschland? Also ich meine, es ist ja sicherlich ein nachvollziehbarer Wunsch, dass man jetzt so einen Wahlvorgang auch in irgendeiner Form teilautomatisiert, damit er einfacher abläuft. Solange man eben sicherstellen kann, dass die Authentizität und Überprüfbarkeit und Öffentlichkeit der Wahl dadurch nicht beeinträchtigt wird. Die Frage ist halt nur, wie. Wenn das eigentliche Problem ein Auszählen ist, dann wäre es ja vorstellbar, dass man Geräte hat, die einem das Auszählen vereinfachen, also dabei helfen sozusagen, so eine Zählhilfe, ohne dass die jetzt wirklich das eigentliche Zählen machen. Ein Gerät, was die Wahlzettel nimmt und vorsortiert und auf irgendwelche Stapel wirft und danach nimmt man sich diesen Stapel und man weiß eigentlich, in diesem Stapel müsste jetzt alles so angekreuzt sein und dann geht man das schnell durch und dann sieht man, hier ist aber einer irgendwie falsch und dann liegt man den auf den richtigen Stapel. Was ist denn davon zu halten?
Ja, das ist natürlich eine Möglichkeit. Aber das Eigenartige ist ja eigentlich, dass diese ganzen Wahlsysteme, die im Wahllokal installiert werden, das Automatisierungsziel oder das Rationalisierungsziel eigentlich gar nicht erreichen. Das heißt, ob du jetzt mit fünf Wahlhelfern oder sieben Wahlhelfern von 8 Uhr bis 19 Uhr oder von 8 Uhr bis 18 Uhr 10 Uhr im Wahllokal bist, das ist einfach nur eine marginale Einsparung an Arbeitszeit und verfehlt das Automatisierungsziel. Eine eigentliche Einsparung an Arbeit würde man erst dann erreichen, wenn man tatsächlich komplett auf eine Distanzwahl umstellt und das zentralisiert machen kann und sozusagen einen großen Stil Wahlhelfer einsparen kann. Aber das ist aus anderen Gründen nicht wünschenswert, weil man dann die Kontrolle aufgibt über die Stimmabgabe und damit auch über die Sicherstellung, dass die Stimmen frei abgegeben werden. Dass also nicht zum Beispiel das Familienoberhaupt für die ganze Familie wählt oder dass Leute ihre Stimmen verkaufen und solche Geschichten.
Das bringt mich jetzt auch noch auf einen wichtigen Punkt, vielleicht auch so den letzten, wenn wir nicht noch was anderes Wichtiges vergessen haben. Diese Distanzwahl gibt es ja und sie heißt Briefwahl. In diesem Fall, du hast es ja schon erwähnt, und ich habe mal nachgeguckt und wenn ich mich nicht verguckt habe, betrug der Anteil der Briefwähler bei der letzten Bundestagswahl immerhin schon bei 18,6 Prozent. Also mit anderen Worten, fast jede fünfte Stimme wurde gar nicht mehr in einer Wahlkabine abgegeben, sondern wurde irgendwo, man weiß nicht wo, und ich würde jetzt auch mal sagen, man weiß eigentlich auch nicht von wem, also offensichtlich, oder man könnte meinen, dass das von der richtigen Person ausgefüllt worden ist, weil diese Person hat das ja per Post erhalten. Und dann wird das eben per Post wieder irgendwo hingeschickt, wo es von irgendjemand, ich weiß jetzt nicht wem, ich war nicht dabei, ausgezählt wird. Was ist denn von der Briefwahl in dem Zusammenhang zu halten, weil die Zahl steigt auch?
Ja, und Briefwahl ist auch eine durchaus problematische Sache, aus meiner Sicht. Eben aus genau diesen Gründen, dass die Stimmen weder kontrolliert abgegeben werden von den Personen, die tatsächlich wahlberechtigt sind, noch man sicherstellen kann, dass die Stimmen frei abgegeben werden, noch man sicherstellen kann, dass die tatsächlich auch so gezählt werden, wie sie abgegeben werden.
Wer zählt dir denn normalerweise?
Die zählen Wahlvorstände. Da gibt es dann sozusagen Briefwahlbezirke, wo um 18 Uhr dann der Briefwahlvorstand anfängt.
Kann man da auch als Wahlhelfer antreten?
Genau, da kann man als Wahlhelfer antreten.
Okay, also es ist sozusagen nur, dass es nicht in einer Kabine ist, aber es ist dann trotzdem so, das geht dann in eine Urne, und die wird dann ausgegossen, und dann wird sie angeguckt.
Genau, das ist auch öffentlich. Also du kannst im Prinzip bei deinem Wahlleiter in deiner Stadt anrufen und sagen, ich möchte gern mal zugucken beim Briefwahl-Auszellen. Das Problem ist also eher, dass man in der Regel nicht weiß, wo das eigentlich ausgezählt wird, wo das Briefwahl lokal ist. Aber das ist prinzipiell auch öffentlich.
Gab es nicht mal ein Urteil vom Verfassungsgericht auch zu Briefwahl?
Es gab zu dem Briefwahl auch ein Urteil vom Verfassungsgericht, das ist aber schon viele Jahre her, das war glaube ich in den 80ern. Und da hat sich das Verfassungsgericht dahingehend geäußert, dass diese Einschränkung der Öffentlichkeit und die Einschränkung der Transparenz und der Kontrolle über die Stimmabgabe hinzunehmen ist, wenn man gleichzeitig entsprechende Vorteile für andere Wahlrechtsgrundsätze hat. Und dazu gehört die Allgemeinheit der Wahl vor allen Dingen. Das heißt, indem man da Leuten ermöglicht, an der Wahl teilzunehmen, die sonst diese Möglichkeit nicht hätten. Das überwiegt in dem Fall das Interesse, über diese Stimme im einzelnen Kontrolle zu haben. Und das ist also ein Abwägen. Und das Verfassungsgericht hat aber auch gesagt, dass das eine Ausnahme ist und das kein Regelverfahren sein darf. Das ist die Frage, bei wie viel Prozent das anfängt. Und es ist, glaube ich, zu Zeiten des Urteils noch deutlich unter 10 Prozent gewesen. Und damals musste man auch, glaube ich, noch an Eides statt versichern, dass man tatsächlich verhindert ist. Wenn du dich erinnerst auf diesen Wahlbenachrichtigungen, du darfst dich wählen.
Ja, ich bin ja kein Bürger dieses Staates. Also zumindest darf ich keine Bundestagswahlen mitgestalten, sondern nur regional.
Also auf den Karten, mit denen man die Briefwahl beantragt, da musste man früher an Eides statt versichern, dass man tatsächlich auch verhindert ist. Das ist inzwischen nicht mehr so.
Inzwischen muss man nur noch die Beantragung zugeschickt.
Man muss aber immer noch wichtige Gründe haben, auch wenn man das nicht mehr an Eides statt versichern muss. Und jetzt hat letztes Jahr der Bundestag noch mal das Bundeswahlgesetz dahingehend geändert, dass es überhaupt keine Vorbedingungen mehr gibt für die Beantragung der Briefwahl. Und das ist eigentlich ganz interessant, weil es ja zeitlich zusammenhängt auch mit dieser Auseinandersetzung in der Wahlcomputersache und sich der Schriftsatz des Innenministeriums eigentlich liest wie ein flammendes Plädoyer gegen die Briefwahl. Da steht nämlich also in aller Ausführlichkeit drin, wie anfällig die Briefwahl ist gegen Manipulationen und wie die Öffentlichkeit da eingeschränkt ist. Und das haben die einfach als Kronzeugen angeführt, dafür, dass die Öffentlichkeit auch schon in anderen Zusammenhängen beeinträchtigt ist und dass es deswegen bei Wahlgeräten auch beeinträchtigt werden dürfte. Aber umgekehrt ist es natürlich schon eigenartig, dass man sagt, die Briefwahl ist so problematisch, da machen wir es einfach mal noch einfacher, die dann auch zu verwenden. Und in der entsprechenden Beschlussvorlage des Bundestages, in dem das dann tatsächlich auch beschlossen wurde, diese Änderung, da steht also ausdrücklich drin, verfassungsrechtliche Bedenken bestehen nicht. Und so viel Mut muss man sich ja aber eigentlich nur machen, wenn man weiß, dass es Bedenken gibt. Denn man schreibt nicht einfach unter jedes Gesetz, verfassungsrechtliche Bedenken bestehen nicht, weil das eigentlich selbstverständlich ist. Dass man keine Gesetze erlässt, gegen die man, gegen deren Verwassungsgemäß halt man Bedenken hat.
Das ist ein bisschen das Pfeifen im Walde.
Ja genau.
Ich hab keine Angst. Ich hab keine Angst. Ich hab kurz mal nachgeschaut, also das Urteil scheint noch sehr viel älter zu sein. Hier steht was von einem Beschluss, 15. Februar 67, dass die Briefwahl sozusagen verfassungskonform sei. Also nicht 80er-Jahre, sondern späte 60er-Jahre ist ja schon eine Weile her, über 40 Jahre.
Ja, also die Daten hab ich jetzt nicht parat.
Die, die alle wissen im Müll, halt sagt das was sie gehabt haben, das stimmt.
Ja, mag so sein.
Ist auf jeden Fall schon eine Weile her.
Auf jeden Fall ist das, hab ich den Eindruck, unter Staatsrechtlern durchaus ein Thema. Und ich glaube, dass das auch durchaus im Rahmen dieses Gesetzgebungsverfahrens kontrovers diskutiert worden ist. Da wurde durchaus auch diskutiert zunächst, das wieder zu verschärfen. Aber die Leute, die da auf der anderen Seite standen, denen die hohe Wahlbeteiligung wichtiger war, die haben dann offensichtlich den größeren Erfolg gehabt. Oder den längeren Hebel.
Tja, was könnte man da tun? Länger wählen. Ich meine, wenn das Problem nur die Verhinderung ist wegen Abwesenheit, das Gute ist, es mag noch Krankheit geben. Ich meine, wie ist das mit Leuten, die jetzt gesundheitsmäßig eingeschränkt sind, die sozusagen aus Krankheitsgründen nicht den Weg in einen, also wo sozusagen auch schon vorher absehbar ist, weil sie bettlägerig sind?
Ja, es gibt ja durchaus Gründe, warum man Briefwahl zulassen möchte. Aber man muss eben auch sehen, dass es negative Seiten hat und problematisch ist. Und tatsächlich ist es auch so, dass da, wo es in der Vergangenheit in Deutschland Probleme gegeben hat mit Wahlen, dass es da eigentlich immer um diese Transparenzlücken oder Briefwahlgeschichten ging. Zum Beispiel Dachau, dieser Kommunalwahl betrug vor ein paar Jahren in Dachau. Das ist eine Briefwahlgeschichte. Da ging es um Wahlen mit Wahlschein und nicht etwa um eine Manipulation im Wahllokal. Und vor ein paar Jahren gab es bei der SPD in Hamburg eine Direktwahl des Kandidaten für den Landesvater im Prinzip. Und da sind also im großen Stil Wahlbriefe verschwunden. Und das ist eben auch eine Briefwahl gewesen und keine Präsenzwahl. Und man merkt einfach, es gibt einige Beispiele für mindestens Unregelmäßigkeiten, was das Briefwahlverfahren angeht, aber es gibt keine entsprechenden Vergleiche oder Probleme oder Beispiele für Probleme bei der Präsenzwahl. Und deswegen muss man sich schon im Klaren sein, worauf man sich da einlässt.
Ja, Ulrich, es war jetzt eine lange Reise. Ich glaube, ich muss dich jetzt auch langsam mal erlösen. Die Erkältung nimmt dich umfangreich im Beschlag. Trotzdem haben wir jetzt noch etwas ganz Dringendes vergessen, was wir vielleicht noch mal sagen müssen. Ich meine, man könnte jetzt noch lang und ewig über die Aspekte der Internetwahl diskutieren. Allerdings sehe ich das auch in dem Zusammenhang mit dem Urteil als noch eine viel größere Büchse der Pandora. Ich meine, wenn der Computer an sich schon das Problem ist, was erst, wenn wir irgendwie alle Computer, die das Internet ausmachen, noch in die ganze Sache mit einbeziehen. Zusätzlich eben noch dasselbe Problem wie bei der Briefwahl. Also wenn man sozusagen alle dieses Präsenzsystem haben will, warum dann irgendwie alle noch von zu Hause vom Sofa aus wählen zu lassen, bis man wirklich sichergestellt hat, dass, nicht mehr sicherstellen kann, dass eine Wahl frei vorgenommen wird. Weiß ich nicht, ob das überhaupt noch irgendeine Zukunft hat, oder?
Ja, das Urteil schließt das nicht prinzipiell aus. Aber ich würde sagen, da muss schon jemand eine tolle Idee haben, wenn das im Rahmen des Urteils tatsächlich funktionieren soll.
Haben wir es, wa?
Ja, ich denke schon.
Super. Tja, gut. Mir bleibt jetzt noch die üblichen Hinweise zu geben, kommentiert. Und gibt Feedback für die Sendung auf den öffentlichen Kanälen, vor allem im Blog, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de. Im Eintrag zu dieser Sendung freuen wir uns immer über Kommentare. Ulrich wird da auch mitlesen. Wenn ihr noch Hinweise habt auf interessante Studien, Wahlvorfälle, sonstige Erkenntnisse oder ob ihr vielleicht auch die Lösung für alle Probleme habt, die hier so aufgezählt wurden, auch wenn wir nicht unbedingt damit rechnen. Ja, ich freue mich auf jeden Fall immer über jede Art von Feedback und wenn ihr Lust habt, verweist auf diese Sendung auch in eurem Blog, wenn euch das gefallen hat. Ich freue mich immer über Erwähnungen von diesem Programm, welches da heißt Chaosradio Express und die Ausgabe Nummer 118 ist jetzt hiermit auch zu Ende. Ich sage nochmal vielen Dank, Ulrich. Und wir sagen Tschüss und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.